frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen
die panne ist leider nicht vorbei
das zeigt auch ein blick in diesem
haushaltsentwurf werden auch immer
geglaubt hat die panini würde jetzt
schnell ändern der sieht es ist leider
nicht so weit und wir haben das auch in
dem einzelplan 15 berücksichtigen müssen
der einzelplan 15 war ursprünglich fast
nur halb so groß wie er jetzt ist und
wir über schalten für das jetzt laufende
jahr überschreiten wir sogar den
einzelplan des letzten jahres das heißt
die kosten sind deutlich gestiegen wir
geben deutlich mehr geld aus und die
frage ist lohnt sich das wofür wird das
geld ausgegeben diese frage muss
beantwortet
und sie kann beantwortet werden wenn sie
darauf zurückblicken was deutschland
bisher geleistet hat wie viel wir
ausgegeben haben dann steht auf der
haben-seite dass wir im vergleich zu
anderen ländern die eine ähnliche
altersstruktur haben wie deutschland die
aber zum teil weniger ältere ungeimpfte
haben dass wir trotzdem eine besonders
niedrige oder verhältnismäßig niedrige
sterblichkeit haben deutschland ist es
also gelungen war der sterblichkeit
einen erfolg zu zeigen auf denen wir
auch stolz sein können und das muss im
rahmen einer solchen debatte auch gesagt
werden wir uns gefragt wofür machen die
das ganze wir haben das gemeinsam
geschafft es sind nicht nur die ausgaben
gewesen es sind auch die vielen menschen
gewesen die sich an die regeln gehalten
haben die kinder die sich die masken
angezogen haben die erwachsenen die
nicht die restaurants die clubs besucht
haben diejenigen die sich an die regeln
gehalten haben sie haben den
allerhöchsten teil der kosten getragen
das sind die immateriellen kosten und
ihnen möchte ich zu beginn dieser rede
meinen ausdrücklichen dank aussprechen
auf der anderen seite sind wir auch an
einen punkt wo wir weitermachen müssen
wir müssen wir müssen uns wir müssen uns
wir müssen uns darauf konzentrieren 200
bis 300 tote pro tag
300.000 neue fälle das ist keine
situation die wir akzeptieren können das
ist eine lage die nicht bleiben kann wir
müssen im kampf gegen krohne
weitermachen es gibt keinen frieden es
gibt keinen grund hier nachzulassen wir
müssen zusammenstehen wir müssen durch
diese schwere werde der bande wir noch
durchkommen daher appelliere ich
übrigens auch an dieser stelle an die
länder wir haben hier ein gesetz gemacht
das infektionsschutzgesetz da hätte sich
der ein oder andere an gesetz gewünscht
wo der bund regeln macht für ganz
deutschland
das ging aber nicht weil wir nicht in
ganz deutschland an der überlastung des
gesundheitssystems haben das wäre dafür
die voraussetzung gewesen aber es gibt
in velen sind sie doch einfach still ich
glaube das was sie hier vorzutragen
interessiert außer ihm eigenen reihen
niemand niemand will das hören
entsprechend das gesamte haus niemand
will das doch hört das ist doch kein
konstrukt ist es doch was sich hier von
der rechten seite was ich hier höre das
ist doch nur störender lärm und so geht
es allen kollegen von mir es ist
beschämend dass man sich das anhören
muss
beschämend
nein es ist nicht das parlament ist das
im parlament geht es um die sachliche
auseinandersetzung aber nicht umhin aber
nicht um hämische bemerkungen im
angesicht und 300 toten pro tag
ich appelliere an die länder ich
appelliere an die länder das
infektionsschutzgesetz was wir jetzt
gemacht haben bitte nutzen sie es nutzen
sie dieses 16 es ist richtig wir haben
nicht deutschlandweit eine überlastung
des gesundheitssystems teil waren
flächendeckende regeln waren nicht mehr
möglich aber es gibt zahlreiche regionen
wo die krankenhäuser zum beispiel
überlastet sind wo die pflege
untergrenzen unterschritten sind wo wir
die notfallversorgung abgemeldet werden
muss verlegt werden muss wo verlegt
werden muss war nicht genug betten da
sind wo wir planbare eingriffe absagen
müssen all diese gegenden sind
überlastet und dort kann und soll das
infektionsschutzgesetz ein gesagt
eingesetzt wird ich bedanke mich
ausdrücklich dafür dass das in
mecklenburg vorpommern aber nicht nur
dort untersucht hat versucht wird denn
wir müssen jetzt zusammenhalten wir
dürfen nicht betonen dass wir die regeln
die wir gerne hätten die aber rechtlich
nicht gehen nicht da sind sondern wir
müssen die regeln die wir gemeinsam
gemacht hat die müssen wir ansetzen zum
schutz all derer die es brauchen die auf
uns angewiesen sind
wir kosten die wir derzeit tragen das
sind kosten da geht es zum beispiel um
impfstoffe die wir besorgen im zentrum
bürger testungen arzneimittel schutz von
versorgungsstrukturen ausgleichszahlung
das ist alles geld was sinnvoll
eingesetzt und das muss ja auch gesagt
wenn wir verschwenden nicht wir
verhandeln hat ja aber das ist das geld
was das gesundheitssystem auch braucht
und das ist insgesamt insbesondere auch
das geld was die krankenhäuser brauchen
denn die krankenhäuser tragen den
schwersten teil der last der versorgung
dieser patienten sagt mehr als zwei
jahren ihnen gebührt mein besonderer
dank insbesondere den pflegekräften aber
auch den ärzten und was man viel zu
wenig wird auch den vielen menschen die
in diesen krankenhäusern arbeiten und
den betrieb am laufen halten das sind
diejenigen denen wir hier dann sind das
sind diejenigen die den mittel zur
verfügung drin
auch die gesetzliche krankenversicherung
hat massive einnahmenrückgänge gehabt
natürlich wegen der wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung wir füttern das war wir
unterstützen das mit 14 milliarden euro
so dass die gesetzliche
krankenversicherung weiter funktionieren
kann für all diejenigen auch die
erkranken und die die hilfe brauchen die
von kogit nicht betroffen sind wir haben
darüber hinaus zwei formen von kosten
die viel zu selten erwähnt werden aber
die in einer haushaltsrede auch erwähnt
werden müssen weil sie da sind weil es
hohe kosten sind das sind zum einen die
kosten die diejenigen tragen die an long
kurven erkannt sind die jugendlichen
jahren longo wieder kann verlieren nicht
nur ihre produktiv für die wirtschaft
ihrer politik steht sondern ihre
lebensqualität verändert sich oft von
heute auf morgen und von dem was wir
jetzt wissen auf unbestimmte zeit longo
wird wird zu den wichtigsten chronischen
erkrankungen in deutschland gehören und
zwar insbesondere auch bei denjenigen
der mittleren lebensphase das können wir
nicht akzeptiert schon alleine deshalb
müssen wir gegen die hohe intelligenz an
kennen und ich möchte hier noch eine
ausdrücklich darauf hinweist es ist die
impfung die auch von longo fidan
sichersten schutz wir haben gott sei
dank ist klarer hinweis darauf dass das
longo witt risiko wenn man in sich
infiziert aber geimpft ist dass das
risiko deutlich reduziert ist und das
ist etwas was wir sagen das sind vorher
trainieren müssen bis heute ebene der
kosten wenn muss sie auch immer wieder
zu kurz kommt das sind diejenigen die
die geistigen die seelischen kosten
tragen das sind diejenigen deren
hochzeit abgesagt wurde der
feier abgesagt wurde ein geburtstag
nicht gefeiert wird konnte wenn es der
letzte geburtstag zum tage wesen des
menschen haben ihren letzten geburtstag
nicht mehr fallen können die
bildungschancen die verloren sind die
kinder die opfer gebracht haben die ihre
freunde nicht besuchen können die
älteren menschen die in den letzten
lebensjahren ihre menschen nicht mehr
sehen konnte auch ihnen schulden wir
dass wir diese pandemie beenden und es
gibt einen weg diese pandemie zu
entgehen sie diesen weg mit mir der weg
der weg aus der familie heraus der weg
aus dem haus was wir jedes mal ist die
allgemeine nebenpflicht war mit der
fluke die wir jetzt haben werden wir im
herbst die gleiche debatte für und die
wir jetzt führen wir werden das land
gehören erneut haben reicht das
infektionsschutzgesetz aus wir werden
die debatte haben was müssen wir
schließen müssen die kinder masken
tragen die gesamte debatte sie kommt
erneut der einzige zuverlässige weg aus
der pandemie heraus ist die allgemeine
impfpflicht es ist auch der weg den die
grund der größte teil der bevölkerung
will ich glaube es auch der weg den der
größte teil des bundestags somit nehmen
wir uns doch die kraft beenden wir die
pandemie in diesem jahr wir haben es in
der hand wir können in diesem jahr die
pandemie beenden und wir sollten diese
gelegenheit nicht verstreichen lassen
wir wollen nicht dass das immer so
weitergeht wir haben die impfstoffe wir
wissen welche varianten im herbst mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit zu erwarten
sind wird wir dürfen nicht warten hier
appelliere ich ausdrücklich auch die
union ich weiß dass in der union viele
sind eher frei ich weiß dass in der
union viele sind bei ihnen nicht rechts
von ihnen bei ihnen sind viele die im
prinzip die allgemeine impfpflicht
richtig finde und mitgehen wollten ich
appelliere einfach an sie wir dürfen es
nicht verschieben wenn wir zu spät
anfangen dass ihr vorschlag ist
unbenommen nicht in jedem punkt falsch
auch wenn wir zu spät beginnen mit der
impfung dann haben wir die impfpflicht
erst durchgezogen für das nächste
frühjahr das kontern zu spät bedenken
sie auch die hohen wirtschaftlichen
kosten denken sie an die enttäuschung
nicht zu erwarten wäre werden wir das
nicht schaffen ich weiß dass wir
miteinander verhandeln müssen habe ich
appelliere an alle die hier vernünftig
sind das können wir gemeinsam bewältigen
die impfpflicht ist was wir brauchen
sonst drehen wir uns im kreis herum und
beenden die pandemie in diesem jahr
nicht dass lehrer eine verlorene
gelegenheit die wir nicht wieder
bekommen werden
und ich möchte mich an die ungeimpften
direkt noch einmal wenden ich möchte
mich an die umgebenden direkten
verwendet nutzen sie wenigstens eine
impfung in diesen tagen denn mit einer
impfung reduzieren sich schon deutlich
sieben tage nach der impfung ihr risiko
intensivmedizinisch versorgt zu werden
oder sogar zu sterben noch nie war das
risiko noch nie war das risiko für die
ungeimpften so hoch sich zu infizieren
und schwer zu erkranken ein großer teil
der 300 menschen die jetzt pro tag
versterben sind ungeimpfte daher
appelliere ich an die umgebung tun sie
sich selbst den größten gefallen die
sich durch sein nächstes schlimmer als
in den letzten tagen bevor der sommer
konto wie eine pause bekommen noch
schwer zu erkranken oder gar zu
versterben nutzen sie die gelegenheit
die wir ihnen wesentlich danke ihnen
karl lauterbach mit einem jahr fast
flehentlichen appell an alle die noch
nicht geimpft sind oder gar gewusst hat
sich impfen zu lassen er sagt nur so
kommen wir aus der premiere aus über
impfungen sonst werde sich im hatte die
er werde sich im herbst spätestens die
debatte über einschränkungen wiederholen
und so und ja uns ein ganz wichtiger
punkt sei eben auch das logo wird
möglicherweise in absehbarer zeit zu
einer der häufigsten chronischen
erkrankungen werde es antwortet ihm
sorgen der gesundheitspolitische
sprecher der unions-fraktion und wir
sind trotzdem parat für das statement
der drei parteivorsitzenden ich sehe
unruhe und wir müssen raus aus dem
bundestag an dieser stelle denn jetzt
gibt es die ergebnisse vom
koalitionsausschuss zu entlastungen für
ist die nicht dass bürgerinnen und
bürger vom zaun brechen aber das zeigt
mir wieder mal mehr dass offensichtlich
eine sehr hohe nervosität bei ihnen
herrscht die allgemeine impfpflicht für
deren mehrheit sicher werden hat in
diesem haus keine mehrheit über kollege
lauterbach und deshalb kann man ja sagen
dass haushaltsdebatten auch immer eine
möglichkeit sind was ganz besonderes
also wir debattieren über grundsätzliche
fragen aber im vergleich zu dem was die
ampel was auch sie sich in den letzten
tagen wieder geleistet haben ist das
hier überhaupt nichts also
widersprüchliche aussagen des
bundesgesundheitsministers bei der frage
finanzierung des gesundheitssystems also
da gibt es dann ein referentenentwurf
der öffentlich publik wird ein tag
später sagen sie ist gäbe gar kein
entwurf zur finanzierung gkv
finanzstabilisierungs gesetz und deshalb
lieber bundesgesundheitsminister machen
sie endlich ernst bessere kommunikation
hatten sie versprochen hatten sie
angekündigt davon ist leider nichts zu
sehen vielleicht klappt das ja in den
nächsten wochen und monaten mal wieder
besser liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir müssen ja auch wieder konstatieren
dass offensichtlich diese einigkeit in
der ampel so nicht besteht wenn dann der
bundesgesundheitsminister verkündet bei
der frage wie deckt er die
finanzierungslücke im bereich der gkv
das sei dann mit dem kanzler
abgesprochen das sei mit dem
bundesfinanzminister abgesprochen und
einen tag später der
bundesfinanzminister lindner sagt das
seien individuelle vorstellung des
kollegen lauterbach da kann ich nur
sagen wenn dann auch noch der
finanzstaatssekretär sagt man warte
erstmal die ergebnisse des
schätzerkreises im herbst es ab dann
kann ich nur sagen wer so
widersprüchlich finanzplanung betreibt
wird kein erfolg haben und noch viel
schlimmer wer solche kabinettskollegen
hat der braucht wahrlich keine
opposition liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und es scheint ja mittlerweile schon zum
guten ton zu gehören das auch innerhalb
des bundeskabinetts es ihre vorstöße
lieber herr bundesgesundheitsminister
nur noch für schulterzucken ja zu
schulterzucken führend beim
infektionsschutzgesetzes haben sich den
bundesjustizminister überrascht bei der
frage der der hot spots beim gkv finanz
stabilisierungs gesetzes ausgerechnet
den finanzminister und insofern kann ich
nur sagen finanzierung des
gesundheitssystems ist eine teamaufgabe
und diese teamaufgabe die sollten sie
auch in der ampelkoalition erfüllen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ich
würde ja auch mal was positives sagen
aber wenn ich mir ganz objektiv die
fakten anschaut dann kann man bisher
sagen jedes einzelne projekt der ampel
ist ein flop ich sage ihnen auch warum
pandemie lage im november in die del
tabelle hinein abgeschafft genießen den
status chaos mit ansage deutscher
sonderweg alle europäischen länder
machen was anderes finanzstabilisierungs
gesetz auf eis gelegt allgemeine
impfpflicht entgegen ihrer behauptungen
die sie aufstellen keine mehrheit im
parlament
infektionsschutzgesetz ging haarscharf
am koalitionsbruch vorbei triage entwurf
arbeitsverweigerung offene
arbeitsverweigerung gegenüber dem
bundesverfassungsgericht und
letztendlich das darf ich eben weil das
kann ich ihnen leider auch nicht
durchgehen lassen sie stellen sich
hierhin loben die pflegekräfte loben die
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter im
medizinischen systeme gesundheitssystem
seit über vier monaten warten die auf
den corona bonus für die mrv es für die
zfs jetzt machen sie endlich ernst mit
den ankündigungen die haben antrag
gestellt stimmen sie diesen antrag zu
dass wir diese wertschätzung auch
tatsächlich konkret den menschen vor ort
zeit und
die liste die wird ja immer länger das
schlimme an der ganzen situation ist ja
dass man sich hier vorkommt wie der der
maler oder täglich grüßt das murmeltier
wir haben vor wochen schon sie gebeten
dass sie auch als bmg mal einer vorhaben
planung vorlegen sie sind mittlerweile
über 100 tage im amt es gibt keine
konkrete vorhaben planung es gibt keine
planung welche vorhaben sie wann die in
welcher zeitschiene umsetzen wollen und
bei dem was sie sagen kann man sich bei
der halbwertszeit ja leider nicht
wirklich darauf verlassen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und weil wir bei den problemen sind
hätte ich mir schon gewünscht dass sie
hier auch mal ein punkte dazu sagen wie
es bei den krankenkassen finanzen
weitergehen soll wie es im herbst
weitergeht und insbesondere wie es bei
der pflegeversicherung weitergehen soll
sie vertragen die frage der
auskömmlichen finanzierung der
pflegeversicherung in eine kommission 20
23 sie geben keine perspektive bei der
frage der krankenhauslandschaft und ich
kann ihnen sagen diese aufschieberitis
wird ihnen auf die füße fällt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der andere
koalition und deshalb
deshalb kommen sie kommen sie jetzt auch
nicht mit dem argument wer in den
letzten jahren regiert hat auch die
kolleginnen der spd und das ich will uns
das jetzt alles erspart aber was sich
bemerkenswert finde ist dass die ampel
für 20 23 in der haushaltsplan und meine
kolleginnen und kollegen werden dazu je
nach konkreter was sagen den etat des
bmg um zwei drittel kürzen und da frage
ich sie allen ernstes ist das genau die
wertschätzung die sie den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums ist dass
die wertschätzung die sie dem
gesundheitssystem entgegenbringen die
sie hier immer proklamieren das ist
fahrlässig das gesundheitsressort spart
am falschen ende liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deshalb lassen sie mir zum
schluss lieber herr
bundesgesundheitsminister noch sagen sie
haben vor einigen tagen ihren
mitarbeitern und mitarbeitern einen
brief geschrieben in dem sie nach 100
tagen im amt gedankt haben haben
geschrieben dass sie den beschäftigten
für die arbeit im ausnahmezustand
ausdrücklich danken das ist richtig sie
haben gleichzeitig aber auch darauf
hingewiesen dass letztendlich die
arbeitsbelastung also der permanenten
ausnahmezustand im arbeitsalltag zu
vermeiden sein sollte und deshalb kann
ich leider nur sagen wenn sie das getan
hätten was sie sagen dann hätten sie
keine kürzung von 65% des bmg etats
bereits im entwurfsstadium zugelassen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
deshalb meine bitte die bitte unserer
fraktion lassen sie sich bei den
haushaltsberatungen nicht vom
bundesgesundheitsminister über den tisch
ziehen sprechen sie vorher mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen dass das was
sie ankündigen tatsächlich auch den
grund mit dem geht was dann tatsächlich
machen vielen dank liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
vielen dank herr sorge
und wir kommen jetzt für bündnis 90 die
grünen zur kollegin dr paula viel futter
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
herr lauterbach
corona ist nicht vorbei das stimmt und
dieser satz wird er jetzt gerade immer
mantraartig wiederholt weil bestimmte
kolleginnen kollegen das auch nicht
verstehen wollen aber eher verdeckt ja
schon so ein stück weit dass die
pandemie sich doch deutlich verändert
hat in den letzten ein bisschen mehr als
zwei jahre und deswegen würde ich sie
gern noch mal kurz mit in das erste jahr
der korona pandemie nehmen da war ich
nicht hier da war ich in der klinik
selber
und da ist tatsächlich so dass wir sehr
viel damit zu tun hatten das uns in der
klinik alle masken geklaut wurden und
nie desinfektionsmittel da bist überall
sicherheitsdienste standen dann gab es
irgendwann das problem dass man nicht
mehr musste wusste welche patienten darf
man jetzt noch behandeln welche nicht
permanent fehlten kollegen in den
dienstplänen und da gebe ich zu da hat
man die debatten hier im bundestag
wirklich nur aus den augenwinkeln
wahrgenommen aber das was man mit
bekommen hat war da wurde geklotzt nicht
gekleckert
da war für alles geld da und es war auch
unglaublich spannend zu sehen obwohl wir
alle immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
haben dass
klinikbetten alleine noch keine
patienten versorgen können dass
beatmungsgeräte allein noch keine
patienten versorgen können das dass der
ganz große schwerpunkt in den crooner
beschaffungen und zusatzausgaben der
monate war und es war das war
tatsächlich ich sage dass deswegen weil
das was mit den beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen gemacht hat wenn du
unglaublich viele lücken im dienstplan
hast und du kommst abends zum
nachtdienst unser motto läuft vorbei an
dem flur der volle betten steht in
originalverpackung die mit boni der
bundesregierung beschafft wurden ohne
dass sie jemals in benutzung gehen
würden und du gehst da hin und du siehst
das geld ist da aber es ist kein kollege
da der mit dir zusammen nach dienst ist
dann macht das was mit dir weil es dir
zeit da denn die falschen prioritäten
gesetzt und wenn du morgens und nach dem
aus der klinik raus kommst du fährst
nach hause und da ist die krone
teststation und du weißt ganz genau da
verdienst ich gerade meine goldene nase
aber an den tarifverträgen der krieg hat
sich nichts geändert das macht was mit
den leuten die im gesundheitswesen
arbeiten und deswegen reicht es nicht
den heute danke zu sagen sondern wir
müssen jetzt in diese phase kommen wo
wir auch die arbeitsbedingungen im
gesundheitswesen dramatisch verbessern
und dafür brauchen wir auch jeden euro
weil wir an diesem tag legen
gesundheitswesen
und er ist einfach unglaublich viel
schief gelaufen das wissen wir alle und
deswegen müssen wir heute auch
kritischer darauf schauen es wurde viel
geld mit vollen händen ausgegeben masken
beschaffung corona teststation diese
betten zuschüsse jahr 50.000 euro ffp
masken ausgabe über die apotheken das
unglaublich viel schief gelaufen und das
muss jetzt vorbei sein ja wir wollen
gewinner beenden und wir wollen alles
was notwendig ist in dieser krise
ausfinanzieren aber wenn wir jetzt
kritisch auf alles drauf schauen was
auch jetzt wieder im einzel kam
drinsteht dann ist es nicht weil wir
coroner nicht beendet worden sondern das
ist wahr wir wissen dass die dass die
mittel in diesem etat jeder euro den man
da dafür finden kann dass die
gesundheitsbedingungen und die
arbeitsbedingungen der beschäftigten
sich verbessern und auch die
patientenversorgung dass die dort noch
besser aufgehoben sind das ist der
einzige grund warum wir so kritisch
darauf schon ich glaube im dritten jahr
der korona pandemie muss man das auch
erreichen können
und da kommen wir auch so ein bisschen
zum grundproblem weil eigentlich sollten
wir ja in der haushaltsdebatte bei einem
einzelplan 15 sollten wir gar nicht so
viel ausgaben kritik an der gkv machen
aber warum müssen wir das machen wir
jetzt quasi eine teilweise
steuerfinanzierten gesetzliche
krankenversicherung haben und es wir
sind als grüne fans der
bürgerversicherung ja aber so ein teil
steuerfinanziertes versicherungskonzept
das ist nicht unsere idee das ist
absoluter weise 1 der vermächtnisse von
jens spahn im gesundheitsministerium
und da müssen wir ganz schnell wieder
davon wegkommen aber wenn das jetzt
gerade so ist und es sieht ja gerade so
aus als ob dass er immer weiter geht
wenn es gerade so ist dann ist es nur
folgerichtig dass auch das
bundesfinanzministerium damit in den
schätzerkreis rein genommen werden muss
und dann ist auch noch folgerichtig dass
auch der haushaltsausschuss und die
aufgabenkritik der gkv einsteigen muss
aber ich halte es nicht für ideal schon
allein weil dann kollegen wie hermann
schwenk mit darüber entscheiden im
schlimmsten fall was im gkv system noch
irgendwas nicht nichts gegen kollegen
mattfeldt aber das ist keine ideale
lösung
naja das zurzeit halt
[Applaus]
und ich habe jetzt ungefähr dreimal
betont wie wichtig bessere
arbeitsbedingungen im gesundheitswesen
sind und natürlich gibt es in diesem
etat entwurf den corona bonus da steht
eine milliarde drin man kann das machen
aber sollte sich niemand der illusion
hingeben dass es und wir hatten ja schon
corona boni in der vergangenheit
deswegen sonnenkorona bonus jemand der
nach fünf nach diensten in folge völlig
ausgebrannt ist um sich fragt ob er in
dieser art und weise diesen beruf in
vollzeit bis zur rente durch steht
deswegen dem corona bonus irgendjemand
nicht in teilzeit geht oder irgendjemand
zusätzlich im beruf bleibt und auch
deswegen ist es wieder ja man kann das
machen aber die frage ist ja was hätten
wir mit dieser milliarde gegebenenfalls
auch eine verbesserung für die
arbeitsbedingungen erreichen können
ja die pandemie ist nicht vorbei aber
die zeit der wenig zielgerichteten
corona maßnahmen und der verschwendung
bei den crooner maßen am bus vorbei sein
und wir brauchen jetzt ein sehr gute
kommunikation zwischen
haushaltsausschuss und dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium
damit wir eine sehr gute gemeinsame
grundlage dafür kommen was wir in diesem
dritten jahr der korona pandemie
zielgerichtet finanzieren können und was
nicht denn wir brauchen jeden euro den
wir da zusätzlich finden können für eine
echte zukunft zuerst der aufstellung
unseres gesundheitswesens das hat echt
auf dem zahnfleisch geht wir brauchen
mehr mittel für eine echte prävention
und 30 jetzt noch mal die punkte an die
im koalitionsvertrag stehe und dass alle
gehörten noch nicht im haushalt des
ministeriums abbilden
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fraktion die linke ich gehe daher auch
die kollegen tun würde jetzt einfach
schnell ganz zum ende
die sorge ich komme auch gerne zu ihnen
wir brauchen jeden euro für eine echte
neue präventionsstrategie und dabei sich
halt die punkte an die alle noch nicht
ausfinanziert dem einzug an ihrem
koalitionsvertrag stehen wir brauchen
auch jeden euro für verbesserungen der
arbeitsbedingungen die dringend
notwendig sind in dieser situation und
wir brauchen auch jeden euro und da
spreche jetzt auch als eine vertreterin
aus sachsen für die sicherung der
medizinischen versorgung und
pflegerischen versorgung im überalterten
ländlichen raum darüber hat hier heute
noch niemand gesprochen auch das wird
eine herkulesaufgabe auch rassist noch
nicht ausreichend abgebildet und auch
das wäre mir die nächsten finden die
vier jahren aus finanzieren müssen
vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin
erhält das wort für die afg fraktion der
abgeordnete wolfgang wille
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist ein
unterschied ob man politik für die
gesundheit macht oder ob man mit
krankheit politik macht es ist ein
unterschied ob man im angesicht
neuartiger gesundheitsgefahren über das
richtige verhalten aufklärt und das
nötige organisiert oder ob man den
menschen angst macht um sich
anschließend als der große retter in
szene zu setzen
es ist ein unterschied ob man gegen neue
erreger impfstoffe entwickelt diese
getestet und sie den menschen anbietet
oder ob man sie den menschen aufzwingt
ohne rücksicht auf deren persönliche
entscheidung und deren grundrechte
dieser unterschied macht sich auch im
haushalt bemerkbar andere länder wie
schweden wo sich keine regierung als
retter aus hochgepuscht angst
aufgespielt hat sind wirtschaftlich viel
besser durch die krise gekommen das ist
freilich ein thema für andere
einzelpläne dieses bundeshaushalts aber
auch der einzelplan 15 zeigt eine
deutliche aufblähung
der haushalt des gesundheitsministeriums
ist mit über 52 milliarden euro so groß
wie nie zuvor und das obwohl der
höhepunkt der krise hinter uns liegt die
gründe dafür liegen in der völlig
verfehlten impfkampagne
so hatte die bundesregierung bereits vor
einigen wochen
677 millionen impfstoff dosen bestellt
teilt man das durch die anzahl der
bundesbürger rund 83 millionen so ergibt
dass mehr als acht impfstoff dosen pro
kopf vom säugling bis zum greis bei
einer quote von 100 prozent
auch wenn viel impfstoff an
entwicklungsländer verschenkt wird zeigt
das klar diese bundesregierung rechnet
mit einem dauer booster zwangs abo für
alle deutschen
[Applaus]
kurz vor weihnachten hatte der einkauf
von kobelt impfstoffen bereits rund vier
milliarden euro verschlungen und für
dieses jahr sind nun über sechs
milliarden angesetzt
millionen bundesbürger haben sich aber
in ihrer persönlichen nutzen risiko
abwägung gegen die im volk entschieden
das hat ganz offensichtlich mit den
teils massiven nebenwirkungen der
impfstoffe zu tun auch wenn diese
offiziell immer noch geleugnet werden
die regierung inszeniert deshalb eine
regelrechte werbematerial schlacht der
haushaltsansatz für
öffentlichkeitsarbeit beträgt nun
215 millionen euro nach gut fünf
millionen euro im letzten jahr das ist
das 40 fache
wir alle wissen dass es auch mit der
werbe schlacht nicht gelungen ist die
menschen in unserem land zu überzeugen
deshalb wird er jetzt über den zwang wir
endlich debattiert und damit das
vertrauen vieler bürger in den staat für
jahrzehnte aufs spiel gesetzt
[Applaus]
heute 2,8 milliarden euro sollen in den
kommenden jahren in sogenannte pandemie
bereitschafts verträge fließen
pharmaunternehmen bekommen dieses geld
damit die kapazitäten vorhalten und
innerhalb von drei monaten die
produktion von impfstoffen hochfranken
nur welches vakzin meine damen und
herren es innerhalb von drei monaten
entwickelt und getestet
natürlich kann man experimentelle
impfstoffe anbieten aber eins muss dabei
ein für alle mal tabu sein nämlich eine
impfpflicht
[Applaus]
diese und weitere ausgabeposten werden
den nächsten wochen gelegenheit
intensiver diskussionen seien auf eins
können sich die deutschen verlassen die
afg wird nie mit krankheit politik
machen und die afg bild immer auf der
seite der freiheit stehen
[Applaus]
vielen dank
nunmehr erhält das wort für die
fdp-fraktion der kollege karsten klein
sagte
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich will so beginnt auch erst
mal allen menschen in diesem land danken
die jetzt in der korona krise die
einschränkungen mitgetragen haben
gehofft haben dass das virus nicht
weiter verbreiten kann die all die
eingriffe ertragen mussten und vor allem
möchte ich mich natürlich und
stellvertretend bei denen bedanken die
in gesundheitssystemen gearbeitet haben
und gearbeitet und dort arbeiten die
pflegerinnen und pfleger aber auch die
vielen helfenden kräfte die deren arbeit
möglich machen und
ich möchte mich ganz besonders nicht so
da sind wir wieder zurück im deutschen
bundestag meine damen und herren nach
diesen presse statement von ricarda lang
lars klingbeil und christian lindner was
haben wir da eben gelernt
senkung der energie steuer auf
kraftstoffe für benzin um 30 cent 14
cent beim diesel in öffentliche
personennahverkehr drei monate lang
jeweils neun euro im monat für ein
ticket eine energiepreis pauschale von
300 euro im monat eine einmalzahlung für
kinder von 100 euro also da kommt eine
menge geld zusammen den betrag machte
christian lesen daneben noch nicht
spezifizieren oder detailliert sagen
weil ja natürlich nach der recht nicht
weiß wie viele beispielsweise dieses und
ppv ticket in anspruch nehmen werden und
welche weiteren unwägbarkeiten da
möglicherweise noch kommen jedenfalls
ein großes paket das viel nützen und
dürften gespannt auf die diskussion die
in kürze einsetzen wird zum gleichen
thema und ihre haare in der suppe da
noch gefunden werden was die abwicklung
beispielsweise angeht und ähnliches oder
auch wie sehr das ganze teil des
ergänzungs haushalt wird und auf welche
art und weise also da gibt es jetzt im
beschluss der koalition aber dass ich
noch nicht das ende der diskussion wir
blicken zurück ins plenum da wird
diskutiert über den etat des
bundesgesundheitsministers und wir sehen
am pult ersten kleinen ideen und man der
fdp fraktion im haushaltsausschuss vor
allem nicht für die die hier die letzten
vier jahre saßen denn wir wissen alle
dass die spanische gesetzgebung ja nach
berechnungen der krankenkassen allein
für über 12 milliarden euro
kostensteigerungen sorgt alles ist ein
problem auf dass wir zu gelaufen sind
und dass uns die vorgängerregierung ja
sozusagen mit auf den weg gegeben hat
und deshalb finde ich sollten alle die
so kräftig nachzahlen fragen einfach mal
eine interne diskussion starten da kann
man vielleicht einiges lernen
herr minister sie haben zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass der bund in dieser
pandemie sehr kraftvoll finanziell auch
agiert hat und nach wie vor agiert
allein in den zwei haushaltstiteln wie
die ausgleichszahlungen im
krankenhauswesen und für die leistungen
im gesundheitsfonds für die zusätzlichen
leistungen im gesundheitsfonds werden
aktuell 26,3 milliarden euro
bereitgestellt
12,5 milliarden euro haben wir für das
thema testen in den letzten monaten
bereitgestellt
1,5 milliarden euro stehen noch mal für
das impfen drin ich will einfach nur
darauf hinweisen dass wir ja natürlich
und es war auch richtig in der krise
kraftvoll agiert haben aber ich will an
der stelle schon noch mal die frage
stellen und die wird in den nächsten
wochen auch im hinblick auf diesem
defizit intensiv zu diskutieren sein
welche rolle eigentlich die länder und
weit ob die länder ihrer verantwortung
bei der finanzierung im
gesundheitssystem und bei solchen
pandemien überhaupt gerecht werden wir
haben für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst einen pakt geschlossen
wo der bund 4 milliarden euro zur
verfügung stellt für eine ureigenste
aufgabe der länder und dass wir nicht in
der lage sind über moderne technologien
in dieser pandemie zu kommunizieren
dafür tragen die länder die
verantwortung dass wir gefasst haben in
einem hoch technik land bei so einer
pandemie dafür tragen die länder die
verantwortung das wäre es längst an der
zeit jetzt nicht nur einzugestehen
sondern endlich auch eigene finanzielle
mittel und kraftvoll dagegen an zu
wirken
der bund hat darüber hinaus im bereich
der digitalisierung der krankenhäuser 3
milliarden euro zur verfügung gestellt
70 prozent der investitionen in die
digitalisierung übernimmt bei diesen
projekten der bund nicht dass sie mich
falsch verstehen ich finde die
digitalisierung im gesundheitssystem
zentral wichtig auch gerade in den
krankenhäusern krankenhäuser und da
besteht auch ein großer nachholbedarf
aber es zeigt doch eklatant wie die
länder ihrer verantwortung nicht gerecht
werden der bundesrechnungshof hat in
seinem bericht noch einmal festgestellt
dass die länder pro jahr eine
finanzierungs investitionslücke von vier
milliarden euro die pro jahr vier
milliarden euro entstehen lassen weil
sie ihre verpflichtungen nicht
nachkommen in die aus infrastruktur in
die gebäude die entsprechenden mittel
zur verfügung zu stellen 4 milliarden
euro und das sind nicht nur
investitionsmittel die vielleicht dann
ein krankenhaus infrastruktur herstellen
sondern da geht es auch um die kosten im
betrieb der krankenhäuser denn veraltete
strukturen führen dazu dass eben keine
moderne technik eingesetzt werden kann
dies sorgt dafür dass wir keine modernen
prozesse und abläufe durchführen können
und die belasten die krankenkassen in
den betriebskosten und damit
letztendlich auch den bundeszuschuss und
damit den bundeshaushalt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deshalb
will ich an der stelle herr minister sie
noch mal auffordern es ist leider in der
letzten legislaturperiode verschlafen
worden aber wir müssen das
kaffeegeschirr mit den ländern endlich
mal zur seite stellen der kraftvolle
pressekonferenzen gibt der sollte auch
kraftvoll agieren wo er in verantwortung
ist und das gehört zur wahrheit auch mit
dazu
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
glaube dass wir beim thema
bundeszuschuss bei der frage wie die bei
krankenkassenbeiträge in der pflege für
sich und austariert werden auch noch mal
klar machen sollten die kollegin die
otter hat es gerade sehr gut schon
formuliert es wird immer mehr auch der
bundeszuschuss hier in die debatte mit
eingebracht und deshalb ist es auch
aufgabe hier im deutschen bundestag über
diese finanzierung zu sprechen auf jeden
fall sollte man wenn man über
aufteilungen und kostenbelastungen
nachdenkt diesen diesen bundestag und
den vor allem dem haushaltsausschuss und
den gesundheitsausschuss auch mit
einbeziehen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
kassen klein war das mitglied im
haushalt obmann im haushaltsausschuss
für die fdp-fraktion der bundestag
diskutiert weiter über den etat des
bundesgesundheitsministers das spielt
natürlich immer mal wieder das thema
corona und anime bekämpfung ein
rolle aber im moment sind die haushälter
gefragt also wie die sich wirklich mit
dem geld beschäftigen gesehen nur
löschen blöd zum beispiel für die
linksfraktion
und bundesminister lauterbach forderte
gesundheit muss einen neuen und größeren
stellenwert in der gesellschaft bekommen
das ist richtig doch hohe lauterbach
bildet sich das im bundeshaushalt ab wir
haben es nicht gefunden meine damen und
herren
stellen wir uns auch nur einmal drei
minute vor aus dem sondervermögen
bundeswehr wird ein sondervermögen
gesundheit was könnten wir mit 100
milliarden euro alles erreichen wir
könnten verhindern dass die
krankenkassenbeiträge weiter steigen sie
dagegen wollen die beiträge noch vor der
sommerpause erhöhen das ist falsch das
leben gehabt meine damen und herren wir
können endlich unsere krankenhäuser
sanieren die linke hat in den
vergangenen jahren immer wieder ein
krankenhaus investitionsprogramm von 50
milliarden euro über zehn jahre
gefordert die hälfte müssten natürlich
die länder tragen oder stellen sich vor
der bundeskanzler eröffnet start einer
neuen autofabrik mal eine neue
geburtsklinik oder eine kinderstation
stadt zeitweise geschlossen werden
oder meine damen und herren wir nutzen
das geld für eine grundlegende reform
des gesundheitswesens wir führen endlich
die bürgerversicherung einen dann
müssten die menschen nicht mehr monate
auf einen termin beim facharzt warten
und wir schaffen endlich die absurden
fallpauschalen ab wir schreiben dann ins
grundgesetz zum thema gesundheit
gesundheit ist keine ware
jeder mensch hat das recht auf eine gute
krankenversorgung wagen sie er ist
fortschritt oder wir starten eine
kampagne wie die bundeswehr es getan hat
aber stattdessen suchen wir pflegekräfte
die für arbeit auch gut bezahlt werden
ein cdu abgeordneter twitterte kürzlich
es muss allen klar sein zitat das die
bundeswehr grundvoraussetzung für unser
leben ist naja ich sage
grundvoraussetzung für das leben ist
erst eine mutter und eine hebamme meine
damen und herren eine umfrage unter
angestellten klinik hebammen ergab dass
90 prozent der befragten überstunden
leisten müssen und keine pause machen
können und die hälfte der hier betreuten
drei frauen parallel das ist doch nicht
zu fassen das muss sich ändern meine
damen und herren wir brauchen also
völlig unabhängig von corona aber corona
ist ja noch eins draufgesetzt wir
brauchen endlich gute arbeitsbedingungen
im gesundheitswesen wir brauchen für die
menschen die in der pflege arbeiten aber
auch alle die in den krankenhaus
arbeiten zu ärzten und ärzte aber auch
die für die logistik zuständig sind
zuverlässige tarifverträge gute
bezahlung und vor allen dingen
arbeitszeiten die auch das leben für
diese menschen lebenswert herzlichen
dank
gesine lötzsch stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion und
haushaltspolitische sprecherin hat jetzt
sich nicht nur über zahlen geäußert
sondern auch über schwerpunkte wie sie
sich vorstellen kann im sektor
gesundheitswesen svenja stadler ist die
nächste rednerin sie kommt aus der spd
fraktion und mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin lieber
gesundheitsminister in lauterbach sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die krankenhaus- und
gesundheitsversorgung ist eine zentrale
säule
unserer sicherheit wenn wir doch im
alltag plötzlich das im alltag
interessen werben durch dem unfall oder
durch ein burnout oder einfach nur durch
eine erkältung dann wissen wir werden
wir aufgefangen manchmal ist dann eine
stationäre betreuung ganz ratsam und der
einen oder anderen stelle hilft auch
eine kur oder eben doch auch einfach nur
medikamente aus der apotheke von nebenan
und wir wissen doch egal ob diese
behandlung 1000 euro kostet oder auch
nur einen euro wir werden in dieser
situation einfach nicht alleine gelassen
und jetzt
müssen wir aber doch genauer hinschauen
wir müssen genauer hinschauen auf unser
gesundheitssystem denn lange wird es das
nicht mehr schaffen die krankenhäuser
versicherung
pflegeeinrichtungen und all die anderen
zusätzlichen player in diesem großen
system sind für uns eine
selbstverständlichkeit
doch es ist immer deutlicher dass eben
diese sicherheit nicht mehr
selbstverständlich ist es fehlen die
fachkräfte doch in den krankenhäusern
und in den pflegeeinrichtungen unter
anderen wir nehmen doch war das
apotheken mehr und mehr schließen weil
die nachfolge einfach nicht geregelt ist
oder gerade in den ländlichen räumen
doch die ärzteversorgung nach und nach
wirklich zu wünschen übrig lässt und
jetzt kommt die digitalisierung dazu die
digitalisierung damit treten auch neue
sucht potenziale auf oder eben auch
körperliche belastung in den
unterschiedlichsten altersgruppen die
müssen wir begegnen und gleichzeitig ist
die digitalisierung die chance für das
gesundheitswesen gar keine frage und
eben nicht nur um bürokratie bauen und
dann gibt es noch die ältere menschen
und die die auch lange krank sind
möglicherweise die wollen aber auch sehr
lange zu hause bleiben und da brauchen
wir flexible
handeln im gesundheitssektor anders ist
es nicht möglich und all das was vor
jahren vielleicht funktioniert hat ist
heute veraltet kann nicht mehr
funktionieren weil es längst überholt
ist und da müssen wir uns doch
selbstkritisch dieser frage stellen dass
wir eben nicht effektiv gehandelt haben
in der vergangenheit dass wir die
falschen wege genommen haben weil wir
nicht selten zielorientierte
entscheidungen getroffen haben und ja
und da stimme ich einen kleinen zu auch
die bundesländer haben nicht ihre wahl
ihrer verantwortung nicht gerecht und
die dürfen da auch einiges tun und
momentan und das finde ich dürften wir
auch nochmal uns anschauen behandeln wir
doch die probleme die sich so auf tun
die krankheiten oder wir lindern doch
nur die symptome nehmen wir doch den
bundeszuschuss einmal den wir stabil
halten oder wollten auf 14,5 milliarden
euro nehmen wir immer wieder dem
gesundheitsfonds zu geben doch nun
stocken wir abermals auf dieses mal
zusätzlich um 21,7 milliarden euro damit
schließen wir auf einen auf der einen
seite die lücke bei der gesetzlichen
kranken finanzierung versicherungs
finanzierung und auf der anderen seite
decken wir aber die kosten aus dem
pandemischen herr sorgen ein brauchen
wir nicht
leistungen wie bürger test versorgungs
ratschlag für krankenhäuser
arzneimittel und eben auch den
schutzmasken und diesen
herausforderungen übrigens derselbe
begegnen wir indem wir nämlich die
gesundheitsfinanzierung weiterentwickeln
wollen und wissen sie schauen sie
einfach im koalitionsvertrag das hilft
lesen hilft wär's kranken
es wird die zeit
denn es wird zeit endlich auch die
ursachen wir müssen uns mit diesen
ursachen befassen die grundlegenden
probleme in diesem system doch erkennen
und dann die richtigen weichen stellen
denn nur so gelingt es uns doch dieses
gesundheitssystem endlich
zukunftstauglich zu machen das ist nicht
einfach und das bedeutet auch harte
auseinandersetzung mit allen playern in
diesem system
aber es ist wichtig die ausstattung in
vielen krankenhäusern ist weit entfernt
von dem was möglich sein könnte deshalb
ist es richtig die nötigen reformen auf
den weg zu bringen dass die modern und
eine bedarfsgerechte
krankenhausversorgung abend auf den weg
bringen können der technologische
fortschritt ist der schlüssel zu mehr
effizienz der alltag der ist nämlich
damit vereinfacht krankheit mit besseren
methoden können wir damit begegnen und
die krisensicherheit auch schaffen mit
187 millionen euro stärken wir deshalb
die forschung und davon fließen alleine
54,2 millionen digitalisierung und
innovation im gesundheitswesen damit
werden wir unter anderem die projekte
zur krisenbewältigung oder auch
maßnahmen zur förderung von
datenverfügbarkeit
finanzieren denn kaum etwas treibt doch
den fortschritt deshalb voran als der
permanente und stetige austausch dieses
teilen von neuen erkenntnissen und eben
auch das gemeinsame arbeiten an
gemeinsamen problemen und das ist nicht
nur national zu betrachten sondern eben
auch global und auch dieser
verantwortung werden wir uns bewusst und
sind wir uns bewusst die pandemie hat es
doch deutlich gezeigt wieder einmal dass
gesundheit nicht an eigenen
staatsgrenzen aufhören darf wir stellen
knapp
159 millionen euro für internationale
aufgaben des gesundheitswesens zur
verfügung und das sind noch einmal 13 8
millionen euro mehr als im letzten jahr
dazu
das finde ich bemerkenswert und deswegen
möchte ich das hier nennen das projekt
der whv pandemic und apple denn
intelligenz in berlin sollten sie sich
vielleicht mal angucken wenn es denn
wenn sie zeit haben hier sorge das
unterstützen wir mit 30 millionen euro
jährlich damit begegnen wir globalen
gesundheitskrise in zukunft geschlossen
und sind auch vorbereitet
vorbereitet sind wir endlich ja
und jetzt möchte ich noch eins
klarstellen an dieser stelle deutschland
steht jetzt kommt
deutschland steht übrigens an der seite
der ukraine ganz klar und deutlich wir
wissen um die menschen die zu uns kommt
und wir wissen um die menschen die mit
verletzungen diesen weiten weg zu uns
geschafft haben wir wissen um die
seelischen verletzungen
die diese menschen tragen und wir werden
diese menschen unterstützen ohne wenn
und aber
insgesamt ist der etat des
gesundheitsministeriums auf knapp 52 56
milliarden euro angewachsen das ist ein
zuwachs von 5 prozent gegenüber dem
vorjahr eine stolze summe die den willen
dieser bundesregierung zeigt dass eben
während der pandemie die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht im stich lässt und
sicherheit garantiert liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen sicherheit muss neu gedacht
werden
sicherheit im wandel ist auch ein
gesundheitssystem im wandel wir sind
bereit dafür lassen sie es uns gemeinsam
anpacken ich freue mich nun auf die
beratung es wird spannend vielen dank
svenja stadler war das orsay
spd-fraktion und da ist oder für die spd
fraktion ist sie mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss und jetzt gibt es
eine kurzintervention
versprochen eine sehr kurze kurz ein
wenn tradition zu machen frau
bundestagspräsidentin dass sie die
kurzintervention zu lassen
schade frau kollegin stadler dass sie
die zwischenfragen zugelassen haben weil
ich wollte sie eigentlich loben ich
wollte ihnen danken und zwar wollte ich
ihnen danken für teile ihrer rede in der
sie ja darauf hingewiesen haben dass
digitalisierung ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt ist gerade für das zentrale system
des gesundheitssystems und deshalb meine
frage sind sie mit mir nicht auch der
meinung dass wir in der letzten
legislatur in der großen koalition also
union und spd gemeinsam auch mit dem
damaligen gesundheitsminister jens spahn
im bereich der digitalisierung viel
erreicht haben und sind sie mit mir
nicht auch der meinung dass wir
gemeinsam union und spd in der letzten
legislatur im bereich der
digitalisierung viel auf den weg
gebracht haben harris innovation hat
beispielsweise die tigers also digitale
anwendungen gesundheitswesen das ganze
thema telemedizin tele consilia
ärztlicher möglichkeiten eröffnet worden
sind also insofern herzlichen dank für
teile ihrer rede in diesem kontext und
würde mich interessieren ob sie das
genauso sehen sich vielen dank
frau kollegin sie können antworten sie
müssen nicht aber sie möchten es
dass sie mich logan wollten finde ich ja
gut dass jetzt gerade nicht so
rausgekommen aber es ist okay ich
finde wir haben tatsächlich in der
letzten legislatur einiges auf dem weg
versucht zu bringen mit ihnen und dann
hat sich ja gezeigt wo die
schwachstellen sind und deswegen nehmen
wir diese schwachstellen jetzt natürlich
auf und werden sie in der ampelkoalition
erfolgreich umsetzen
eine kurze antwort auf eine kurze
kurzintervention war das und da sie
häufiges publikum sind haben sie die
systematik auch dieser debatte natürlich
längst durchschaut und ich muss gar
nichts dazu sagen denn wir haben
gewonnen sie haben natürlich gemerkt
dass die letzten geräte närrinnen
überwiegend mitglieder des
haushaltsausschusses gewesen sind und
dass es jetzt weitergeht wieder mit den
fachpolitikern
zum thema gesundheit und
gesundheitswesen dietrich mond stadt aus
der unionsfraktion ist der erste in
dieser reihe
der artikulieren politische wille hören
sie etwa zu bevor sich beschweren der
artikulieren politische wille der
regierung mehr für eine bessere
gesundheitliche versorgung zu tun kommt
in diesem haushalt jedenfalls nach
unserer wahrnehmung nicht zum ausdruck
auch die bisherige bilanz ist ich darf
das mal so formulieren durchaus
überschaubar mein kollege tino sorge hat
hierzu wie ich finde zutreffend
ausgeführt und frau kollegin dr.in rufe
ich zu was hat sie davon abgehalten in
dieser koalition das was sie hier
gefordert haben auch tatsächlich
umzusetzen
darüber sollten sie mal nach decken
meine damen und herren
bekanntermaßen liegt mir die bekämpfung
einer der größten volkskrankheiten
deutschlands diabetes mellitus und die
versorgungssituation der betroffenen
besonders am herzen gemeinsam haben wir
als union mit der spd in der letzten
legislaturperiode einen umfassenden
antrag zur einführung einer nationalen
diabetes strategie mehrheitlich hier im
bundestag beschlossen es läge nun an der
neuen regierung im sinne der über 10
millionen betroffenen die angesprochene
intensivierung der bekämpfung von
diabetes mellitus auch umzusetzen
bedauerlicherweise ist eine
weiterentwicklung und umsetzung dieser
nationalen diabetes strategie in diesem
haushalt nicht abgebildet die geplanten
ausgaben für aufklärung prävention soll
nicht etwa erhöht werden wie man bei
begriff intensivieren meinen könnte die
ansätze der vorjahre bleiben gleich sie
werden nicht angehoben das heißt vor dem
hintergrund der aktuellen inflation
sinken die real zur verfügung stehenden
finanzmittel worte und handelns stehen
im krassen widerspruch
meine damen und herren auch bei der
erkrankung an die positiv besteht
dringender handlungsbedarf
13 prozent der kinder und jugendlichen
sind von übergewicht betroffen
acht prozent der kinder von adipositas
67 prozent der männer und 53 prozent der
frauen sind übergewichtig
und 23 prozent der männer und 24 prozent
der frauen adipös die aus eigener
betroffenheit kann man da gut drüber
reden das stimmt da haben sie recht
übergewicht und adipositas
begünstigen viele chronische krankheiten
die dann beträchtliche kosten für die
gesundheits- und das sozialsystem
auslösen es ist daher von herausragender
bedeutung in diesem bereich präventiv zu
handeln
und ich frage sie herr minister ganz
konkret wollen sie dass unsere kinder
immer dicker werden wollen sie dass sie
als erwachsene potenziell an diabetes
erkranken auch hier minister brauchen
wir die die ihnen diesen tagen viel
beschworenen zeitenwende
meine damen und herren aus den oben
beschriebenen problemen folgt nach
meiner auffassung dass wir das
vergütungssystem die zahlung an die
selbstverwaltung also den sogenannten
morbi-rsa neu justieren müssen weg von
kurativen behandlungsansätzen hin zu
mehr prävention und verhaltensänderung
ziel muss sein bereits die entstehung
von vermeidbaren krankheiten zu
verhindern wesentliche
verhaltensveränderungen müssen motiviert
werden
meine damen und herren weitere wichtige
ansätze aus der letzten
legislaturperiode
werden ebenfalls nicht in der
erforderlichen intensität angegangen wie
beispielsweise das in der apotheke
nintendo prothesen register deutschlands
ein register dass die operation daten
der krankenhäuser sammelt und analysiert
die transformation dieses privat
aufgebauten registers in den
öffentlichen bereich droht zu scheitern
man lässt unter völliger verkennung der
ausgangssituation zu dass durch eine
mangelnde datenerfassung die
vielfältigen aussage möglichkeiten
dieses registers verloren gehen auch
hier finden sie im haushalt leider keine
ansetzen
insgesamt ist sie festhalten dass diese
haushaltsentwurf keine verbesserung für
die gesundheit der menschen in
deutschland erkennen lässt ich hoffe
dass wir in den kommenden
haushaltsberatungen noch notwendige
anpassungen vornehmen können herzlichen
dank
dietrich monstadt für die union im
gesundheitsausschuss
und für die fraktion bündnis 90
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
mit dem themenschwerpunkt gesundheit
unter anderem ist maria klein schmeink
und wie wird jetzt aufgerufen werden von
bundestagsvize präsidentin aydan özoguz
und da ist sie schon auf dem weg
und kollegen ich finde es eigentlich
bedauerlich dass das niveau der debatte
eigentlich der größe der aufgabe nicht
wirklich gerecht wird das finde ich
natürlich bedauerlich weil wer sich mal
klarmacht wie wichtig es ist dass ich
für die großen existenziellen fragen
insbesondere die unversehrtheit des
körpers aber auch eben in der frage
gesundheit versorgung bei pflegebedarf
dass das die größten fragen sind die
eine bevölkerung umtreiben und wer
erlebt das deutlicher als diejenigen die
jetzt gerade in der ukraine erleben wie
schlimm es ist wenn genau das nicht
gewährleistet ist und das zeigt sehr
deutlich wie wichtig unsere aufgabe ist
die wir hier gemeinsam zu bearbeiten
haben das gilt für den bereich der
gesundheit das gilt für den bereich der
pflege und wir haben mit der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherungen und
mit der pflegeversicherung
wirksame instrumente um diese sicherheit
zu schaffen und auch zu finanzieren
und da ist es unsere aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass diese versicherungssysteme
mit dieser aufgabe auch mitwachsen
können und dem gericht werden was der
anspruch und decke der berechtigte
anspruch der bevölkerung ist und da
reicht es nicht darauf zu verweisen man
könnte doch man sollte doch sondern wir
müssen ganz konkret liefern und leisten
und genau da
haben wir große herausforderungen vor
uns wir haben 16 jahre cdu geführte
union die uns eine riesiges defizit in
der gkv hinterlassen hat wir haben eine
haben 16 jahre union geführte regierung
die uns an eine fast nicht
handlungsfähige soziale
pflegeversicherung hinterlassen hat und
wir haben neue aufgaben zu stemmen
einmal mit der pandemie zweitens mit der
aufnahme der vielen vielen geflüchteten
die jetzt zu uns kommen und fast alle
auch einen hohen versorgungsbedarf haben
das sind die herausforderungen die wir
zu stemmen haben und das können wir nur
gemeinsam gemeinsam mit dem
gesundheitsminister und gemeinsam hier
im parlament müssen wir dafür die
voraussetzungen
und wenn ich da sehe er sorge wie
selbstgefällig sie hier sich hinstellen
groß etwas einklagen aber nicht einmal
im ansatz
problemlösungen geliefert haben weder
jetzt das auf scheint wie wollen sie
denn diese finanziellen probleme lösen
noch dass sie in politischer
verantwortung in der letzten wahlperiode
in der mittelfristigen finanzplanung in
ihren konzepten im wahlprogramm auch nur
eine antwort dafür geliefert hätten wie
sie diese probleme lösen wollen und das
verlange ich natürlich auch von einer
opposition wir haben das in den jahren
und wir haben viele jahre miteinander
gerungen haben wir das immer wieder
geliefert und ich erwarte dass auch von
ihnen
und wir haben in der ampelkoalition
einige stellschrauben verabredet wie wir
dieses geerbte defiziten lösen wollen
wir haben vereinbart dass es eine
dynamisierung des bundeszuschusses gibt
der im übrigen für versicherungsfremde
leistungen aus gekehrt wird und nicht
für die aufgaben der gkv sondern für
versicherungsfremde aufgaben sie haben
in den letzten jahren viele viele
aufgaben als es noch überschüsse gab
immer wieder in eine richtung geschoben
nämlich in die gkv und zusätzlich in die
spv dann haben wir eine große aufgabe
vereinbart dass wir die kosten der
beiträge für alle' g2 beziehende endlich
anpassen dass die beiträge ebenso
refinanziert werden dass sie auch
annähernd dem entsprechen was der umfang
der belastung für die gkv garros wird
und diese frage wird immer wichtiger
werden weil wir jetzt über 200.000
geflüchtete dazu bekommen die natürlich
nach einer gewissen zeit auch in diesem
regel kreislauf kommen dann haben wir
über haben wir vereinbart die übernahme
der rentenbeiträge für pflegende
angehörige in der spv auch das eine ganz
ganz wichtige aufgabe die da gesetzlich
und gesellschaftlich geleistet wird sie
haben dafür gesorgt dass das nur dem
versicherten aufgabe über geholfen wird
und eben nicht steuerfinanziert über den
haushalt finanziert da haben wir eine
aufgabe die zu lösen ist weiterhin haben
wir das problem in der stv dass die
häusliche krankenpflege noch immer nicht
adäquat refinanziert wird auch das wird
etwas sein was wir zu lösen haben wir
haben also in der ampel vereinbarung
getroffen wie wir diese strukturellen
probleme lösen würde wir haben
gleichzeitig aber auch viele viele
ansätze
verankert und vereinbart wo wir die
überfälligen antworten liefern wollen
die da sind wie große krankenhaus reform
die große reform der grundlegenden
versorgung im land diesen raum wir haben
viele viele aufgaben die wir
insbesondere auch bei der
fachkräftesicherung zu stemmen als das
geben wir an und dafür werden wir auch
sorgen und wir werden dafür sorgen dass
das verlässlich stabil finanziert wird
und darum werden wir in den nächsten
wochen bringen und ich hoffe sie machen
konstruktiv mit und nicht nur mit einer
billigen polemik die jede antwort
vermissen ist
maria klein schmeink stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen der bundestag diskutiert nach wie
vor über den einzelplan 15 dass es der
für das gesundheitsministerium und der
sind einige defizite aufzuarbeiten und
jetzt sehen wir hier ein sonderfall von
mund nasen schutz bei christin ambaum
afd fraktion und zahnärzte
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
es ist die gesundheit die der wahre
reichtum ist nicht gold und silber
stücke das zitat ist von mahatma gandhi
nicht erst seit corona wissen die
deutschen ihr bisher gut
funktionierendes gesundheitssystem zu
schätzen noch bis vor wenigen jahren gab
es fast in jeder größeren gemeinde einen
hausarzt an den zahnarzt eine apotheke
und in unmittelbarer nähe leicht
erreichbar auch ein krankenhaus und
fachärzte doch diese grundstrukturen
bürgern immer mehr vor allem im
ländlichen raum der dadurch immer
unattraktiver wird viele ärzte nehmen
neue patienten gar nicht mehr auf weil
sie bereits überlastet sind
terminvergaben in sechs monaten oder
noch später sind keine seltenheit mehr
wie viel teurer die behandlung dadurch
werden weil sich der gesundheitszustand
der patienten bis zum sehnlichst
erwarteten termin bereits drastisch
verschlechtert hat ist nicht
verifizierbar auch nicht wie viele
patienten eventuell in der zwischenzeit
verstorben sind
verantwortlich für die inzwischen akut
gewordenen mini serien sind die
regierungen der letzten jahre denn die
probleme sind seit langem bekannt
doch auch mit der neuen regierung ist
keine besserung in sicht trotz der
unglaublichen steigerung der ausgaben
von 15,3 milliarden im jahr 2009 10 auf
über 52 milliarden in diesem jahr kein
cent davon kommt zum beispiel in der
pflege an die schlimmste entwicklung von
allem jedoch ist die profitorientierte
krankenhauspolitik durch das drg
fallpauschalensystem wurde unsere
gesundheit zur ware durch den
ökonomischen druck wird nur noch
geschaut mit welcher behandlung das
meiste geld zu verdienen ist diese
entwicklung muss gestoppt werden
gesundheitsversorgung ist
daseinsvorsorge und eines kann ich ihnen
versprechen wenn ich mit ihren
beamtenapparat den aktuellen haushalt
durch gehe dann finde ich genug geld um
unser gesundheitssystem wieder auf
vordermann zu bringen eine verstümmelung
unserer kinder verharmlosend und
irreführend geschlechtsumwandlung
genannt wird wenn mir ebenso gestrichen
wie alle ausgaben zu gender ideologie
oder dem fiktiven kampf gegen rechts der
nichts weiter als ein kampf gegen die
opposition darstellt
und hören sie endlich auch ein ganzes
volk zu bevormunden
glücklichsein zufriedenheit und
lebensfreude sind die wichtigsten
voraussetzungen für unser aller
gesundheit der gesundheit beruht auf
einem gleichgewicht zwischen körper
seele und geist wie zuvor wurde dieses
gleichgewicht so zerstört wie durch ihre
corona maßnahmen werden sie endlich die
maske zusammen mit allen maßnahmen und
deren pflicht in die mülltonne denn dort
gehören sie hin vielen dank
[Applaus]
und es folgt die kollegin für die
fdp-fraktion nicole vastic und
nicole westliches pflegepolitische
sprecherin der fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen kommen wir zurück zur sache und
zur
gesundheitspolitik
als
fortschritts koalition begegnen wir den
vielfältigen herausforderungen die hier
alles schon genannt worden sind mit
einem großem verantwortungsbewusstsein
gegenüber der aktuellen und generation
und den künftigen generationen
eine große baustelle in unserem
gesundheitswesen ist die pflege und das
nicht erst seit der pandemie wenn wir
patientinnen und patienten
bedarfsgerecht versorgen wollen wenn
menschen in würde alt werden sollen dann
müssen wir hier endlich an
die segel steht deshalb weit oben auf
der agenda dieser koalition wir wollen
die arbeitsbedingungen dort nachhaltig
verbessern das gelingt uns jedoch nur
dann wenn wir den personalmangel mangel
beheben und mehr menschen für die pflege
gewinnen deshalb müssen wir in die
bildung in ausbildung und akademisierung
investieren gemeinsam mit den ländern
wollen wir pflegewissenschaft und
pflegeforschung voranbringen diese sind
kein selbstzweck sie geben uns
evidenzbasierte antworten auf die fragen
nach einer guten und bedarfsorientierten
patientenversorgung
das kommt uns allen als gesellschaft zu
eine besondere rolle spielt dabei auch
die pflege pädagogik denn zu viele
lehrerinnen und lehrer fehlen an unseren
pflegeschulen was mitunter zur
schließung führt das muss sich ganz
schnell ändern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es kommt
auf jeden ausbildungsplatz an deshalb
ermöglichen wir die pflegeausbildung
künftig auch an reha kliniken ein
weiterer baustein für mehr
pflegepersonal liegt natürlich in der
zuwanderung deshalb ist es gut dass sich
diese koalition ganz klar dazu bekennt
deutschland zu einem modernen und
weltoffenen
einwanderungsland zu machen
was sie damit ein problem haben das
wissen wir
allerorten haben wir fachkräftemangel
aber nirgends vetter und so übel auf die
füße wie in der pflege mit diesem
haushalt fordern wir auch die
möglichkeit
pflegekräfte im ausland nach deutschem
standard auszubilden doch das ist nicht
genug bei der gewinnung der besten köpfe
konkurrieren wir mit ländern in denen
pflegende eine größere autonomie haben
als bei uns deshalb ist es wichtig die
halbrunde übertragung endlich umzusetzen
denn pflegende können mehr als sie
dürfen
und wir sind die koalition die den
menschen etwas zutraut das hat auch
etwas mit wertschätzung zu tun und diese
brauchen wegen der wieder
mit mittel community herzens schaffen
wir ein neues berufsbild
hochqualifiziert sollte die pflegerische
versorgung gerade im ländlichen raum
mitgestalten
sie hilft damit menschen auch mit
pflegebedarf länger in ihrer gewohnten
umgebung bleiben zu können und sie
stärkt fliegenden angehörigen den rücken
denn liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
pflege in unserem land ist zu einem ganz
großen anteil angehörigenpflege fast ein
viertel aller pflegebedürftigen werden
zu hause von angehörigen betreut diese
menschen brauchen dringend unterstützung
deshalb wollen wir die kurzzeit und
verhinderungspflege
wege zu einem flexiblen entlastungs
budget zusammenfassen die pflegegeld
leistungen wollen wir dynamisieren und
mehr kurzzeitpflegeplätze schaffen
und damit ist es nicht getan aber
wichtig ist dass wir endlich anfangen
hier entlastung zu schaffen als
fortschritts koalition wollen wir
entbürokratisieren vereinfachen
beschleunigen und vernetzen gerade im
gesundheitswesen und dabei endlich den
digitalisierung stau in unserem land
beheben überbordende dokumentation muss
auf den prüfstand
machen wir es pflegenden mit digitalen
anwendungen so einfach wie möglich
schenken wir ihnen mehr zeit nutzen wir
kalium pflegebedürftigen und pflegenden
angehörigen das leben zu erleichtern
wir stärken aber auch unsere kommunen
denn sie wissen am besten wie sie ihre
quartiere für ein gutes leben im alter
auch mit pflegebedarf gestalten wir
fördern innovative wohnformen das
pflegeheim sollte stets thiele aller
letzte station sein damit das gelingt
setzen wir als ampelkoalition verstärkt
auf prävention und rehabilitation pflege
bedarf hinaus zu zögern
lebensqualität bis hin zur alter zu
ermöglichen das ist das gebot der stunde
und dafür setzen wir uns mit aller kraft
ein vielen dank
nicole war dass die pflegepolitische
sprecherin der fdp-fraktion hier wird
jetzt folgen hat oettinger aus der
fraktion die linke der sprecher für
krankenhaus und pflegepolitik
und jetzt ermahnt
bundestags-vizepräsidentin
aydan özoguz nochmal die abgeordneten
die zeit einzuhalten sie lobt sie vor
allem dass es so gut gelungen ist
bislang und schau mal ob ich glücklich
dass auch im krieg der hat nur zwei
minuten die ampel einigen ich heute auf
ein entlastungspaket und sie herr
lauterbach kündigen eine erhöhung der
krankenkassenbeiträge an ist das
eigentlich schon satire herr lauterbach
ersparen habe bereits alle ersparnisse
der krankenkassen munter aufgebraucht ja
wenn wir hier nicht tätig werde im haus
dann drohen ab 20 23 spätestens 20 24
massive steigerungen für die beitrags
zahlen beiden krankenkassen aber das
bedeutet noch eine aufgabe für sie eher
lauterbach sie haben noch eine funktion
das zu verhindern sie müssen eine
ordentliche reform auf die reihe bringen
herr lauterbach das ist ihre aufgabe
das ist ein bruch der versprechen aller
koalitionsparteien die normal
verdienenden nicht zusätzlich zu
belasten
denn was werden die leute in ihrem
geldbeutel richtig spüren bei 17
milliarden euro die den kassen fehlen da
geht es cirka um 1 prozentpunkt das
bedeutet lohnkürzung meine damen und
herren nichts anderes bedeutet das und
das dürfen sie nicht zulassen bei den
jetzigen preisen bei der inflation
dürfen wird das nicht zulassen stoppen
sie das herr lauterbach schaffen sie
eine solidarische
gesundheitsversicherung in die alle
einzahlen ohne
beitragsbemessungsgrenze so dass auch
wir die wir so schön sitzen endlich was
ordentliches dazu beitragen dann würden
die beiträge sogar sinken der
lauterbacher herr scholz hat bei manchen
ministern gestern einen dank verteilt
sie ja lauterbach waren nicht dabei
machen sie sich nichts daraus ein dank
vom kanzler ist nichts wert denn wie sie
bedankte er sich in seiner rede einmal
mehr auch bei denjenigen die uns durch
die pandemie bringen mit dem ganzen
genöle was ich pflegekräfte
rettungssanitäterin und medizinische
fachangestellte seit zwei jahren anhören
müssen er dankte sie klatschten dann
meinte er stolz dass es damit nicht
getan sei und es folgte in seiner
erläuterung ausführungen nichts nichts
für die pflegekräfte medizinische
fachangestellte nicht für die
rettungssanitäter für die die uns durch
die pandemie bringen folgte nichts herr
lauterbach ein dank vom kanzler ist also
generell relativ wenig wert warten sie
nicht darauf tun sie was wenn sie sich
am ende von den pflegekräften von den
patienten und patienten beitrag zahlen
von denen einen dank abholen dann haben
sie wirklich was geschafft deswegen ende
ich nicht mit vielen dank sondern
bringen sie endlich was auf die reihe
fort schaffen
hat der göttinger aus den fraktionen
reklamiert dass zu wenig für die
pflegekräfte getan werde auch im etat
des neuen bundesgesundheitsministers
vielleicht gibt es noch dazu von heike
behrens der gesundheitspolitischen
sprecherin der spd fraktion dazu
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
trotz der großen krisen die diesen
haushaltsplan prägen hat bundeskanzler
olaf scholz gestern in seiner
generaldebatte deutlich gemacht dass ihr
das nicht vernachlässigt wird was wir
uns für die zukunft vorgenommen haben
aufbruch und fortschritt gestalten das
werden wir auch unter diesen schwierigen
bedingungen in der gesundheitspolitik
tun
schauen wir auf die digitalisierung und
zwar nicht nur in den schulen und in den
verwaltungen sondern gerade auch im
gesundheitswesen wir werden diesen
rückstand aufholen der heute schon
mehrfach angesprochen worden ist denn
digitalisierung kann dinge einfacher
machen für patientinnen und patienten
die bessere und passgenauere
vorsorgeangebote bekommen für reisende
die ihren impfpass einfach auf dem
smartphone dabei haben können für
pflegende die weniger zeit für
bürokratie verschwenden müssen für die
forschenden die besseren daten für ihre
arbeit brauchen und für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst der starker und
moderner werden muss daran arbeiten wir
daran arbeiten wir nicht nur mit neuen
gesetzen sondern auch indem wir uns
intensiver um die umsetzung kümmern
das haben wir uns als fortschritts
koalition vorgenommen und dabei erwarten
wir eine konstruktive mitarbeit aller
beteiligten im gesundheitswesen denn
wenn wir erfolgreich sind mit der
digitalisierung dann können auch
argumente wie papier mangel nicht mehr
vorgeschoben werden muss
moderne
gesundheitspolitik
braucht aufgeschlossenheit und
gestaltungswillen auf allen ebenen der
selbstverwaltung aufbruch und
fortschritt braucht es unbedingt aber
auch in der pflege auch das hat die
pandemie nachdrücklich gezeigt da knüpfe
ich gern an dem an was bei west ich eben
schon gesagt hat und gute pflege geht
nur mit stabiler und solider
finanzierung und deshalb braucht die
soziale pflegeversicherung
dauerhaft einen ordentlichen
bundeszuschuss
aber auch über diesen ersten schritt
hinaus müssen wir für eine nachhaltige
finanzierung der pflege sorgen damit das
gelingen kann was wir uns vorgenommen
haben denn wir wollen die belastung der
pflegebedürftigen in grenzen halten bei
den eigenanteilen in der stationären
pflege mit der einführung des flexiblen
entlastungs budgets für alle die zu
hause gepflegt werden und durch die
regelhafte dynamisierung des
pflegegeldes wir werden pflegebedürftige
und ihre angehörigen durch den ausbau
der tages- und nachtpflege starken und
wir werden diejenigen starken
nachdrücklich starken die in der pflege
arbeiten sie brauchen endlich bessere
arbeitsbedingungen
sie müssen sich auf ordentliche
personalschlüssel in den krankenhäusern
und in dem pflegeheim verlassen können
und ebenso auf eine gute bezahlung und
dazu
und dazu braucht es auch die stärkung
der pflege in den gremien der
selbstverwaltung
aber auch hier in der pflegepolitik gilt
alle akteure müssen an einem strang
ziehen da sind die arbeitgeber genauso
gefordert innovative und
familienfreundliche arbeitszeitmodelle
endlich auch in der praxis umzusetzen
und da will ich nochmal an den kollegen
kleinen anknüpfen die länder müssen
endlich in vollem umfang die
verantwortung tragen für die
investitionskosten finanzierung unserer
krankenhäuser und auch der pflegeheim
denn sonst leicht diesjährige
unterfinanziert komme zum schluss liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
zukunfts koalition sein das bedeutet
strukturen zu schaffen die über die vier
jahre dieser legislaturperiode
hinausreichen und ich freue mich auf die
gemeinsame zusammenarbeit
vielen dank kollegin behrends und es
folgt gleich
für die cdu/csu-fraktion der abgeordnete
michael hennrich
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
haushaltswoche bietet immer eine
wunderbare gelegenheit bilanz zu ziehen
und nach 100 tagen ampel regierung ganz
besonders und das ist ein gutes signal
so wie sie ist hat er auch formuliert
haben dass das thema gesundheit
gesundheitsschutz nicht am geld
scheitert aber was mich stört ist
dass wir in den letzten wochen und
monaten nur über das thema pandemie und
cupid gesprochen haben und so sehr ich
sie liebe herr lauterbach geschätzt
haben den schwierigen monaten der
pandemie wo sie klaren kurs gefahren
sind um so mehr verzweifle ich momentan
an der politik in der pandemie dass sie
dass sie weder für klarheit sorgen was
die zukunft des gesundheitssystems leben
dass sie keine orientierung schaffen
wenn ich einfach mal revue passieren
lasse die impfkampagne wir hatten eine
diskussion
die sie angezettelt haben zum ende des
jahres ist er zu wenig impfstoff da
heute sehen wir dass impfstoff auf der
halde liegt wir haben eine völlig
verquere debatte um das thema
impfpflicht das wäre meines erachtens
ihre aufgabe gewesen vernünftigen plan
vorzulegen abgestimmt mit den
koalitionspartnern und nicht das
instrument der gewissensentscheidung
dabei zu reden jetzt stehen wir vor den
scherben dieser debatte der impfpflicht
und es geht weder vor und zurück und
auch das thema
infektionsschutzgesetz hat spuren
hinterlassen aber wichtiger viel
wichtiger ist mir dass sie von ihrer
modus pandemie minister endlich wechseln
in den modus gesundheitsminister dass
sie die struktur reform vornehmen die
auch die wir alle warten und das
allerwichtigste ist dass sie unsere
eigenen vorhaben planen unter dem
minister sparen wussten wir für ein jahr
genau was an gesetzesvorhaben kommen
soll bisher steht da auf der habenseite
nichts sie haben vor kurzem
einen finanzierungs entwurf im bereich
arzneimittel vorgelegt über den sich
wirklich lohnt zu diskutieren und da
gibt es sicher elemente die auch eine
unionsgeführte regierung eingeführt
hätte öffentlich regelung
rückwirkung des erstattungsbetrag es
bezahlbarkeit von kombinationstherapien
vorwurfs problematik des in alles dinge
über die sich lohnt zu diskutieren
aber ich glaube ganz offen zu ich halte
es für fatal
wenn sie jetzt den einzigen
wirtschaftsbereich der in deutschland
international bestens positioniert ist
nämlich die pharmaindustrie wir haben es
endlich wieder geschafft so ein stück
weit apotheke der welt zu werden wenn
sie dort für verunsicherung sorgen
diskussionen um herstellerabschlag und
ähnliches das ist ein fatales zeichen
was
investitionstätigkeiten internationale
konzerne angeht und ich bitte sie
eindringlich dass zurückzunehmen
und ich wähle sie auffordern endlich
auch nur deutlich zu machen wie es
weitergeht mit dem thema digitalisierung
jens spahn hat es wunderbar aufs gleis
gesetzt bei ihnen habe ich jetzt den
eindruck dass sie wieder die räder
zurückdrehen wollen dass es im kern
keine keine elektronische patientenakte
geben soll keine rezept das ganze thema
wie geht es weiter mit den apps wie
können wir effizienzreserven heben bis
zum heutigen tage nichts gehört das
gehört zu ihren aufgaben wir als
koalition wir würden uns gern wir als
opposition würden uns gern mit ihnen
steigen aber da ist sind zwei dinge
voraussetzungen erstens legen sie pläne
vor und noch viel wichtiger kommen sie
auch um in den gesundheitsausschuss um
mit uns diese dinge zu diskutieren
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank
und als nächste rednerin volk für bundes
90 die grünen kordula schulz asche
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir erleben gerade die erschütterung
europas durch den krieg gegen die
ukraine millionen menschen jeden alters
flüchten aus ihrem land und viele davon
zu uns wir müssen befürchten dass dieser
krieg länger dauert und deswegen stehen
wir hier zusammen auch im kampf für
demokratie und frieden in der ukraine
aber auch weltweit wir müssen aber auch
darauf achten
dass euch durch solche entwicklungen
andere krisen nicht in vergessenheit
geraten dazu gehört die der
demografische wandel den wir in
deutschland in den nächsten jahrzehnten
erleben werden und dazu gehört der
pflegenotstand den es schon vor corinna
gab aber der natürlich durch die
kampagne sich erheblich verschärft hat
und deswegen wird diese regierung
handeln und ich möchte meinen
vorrednerin frau westig und frau behrens
ausdrücklich danken für ihre beiträge
lassen sie mich aus meiner sicht noch
einmal einige punkte hervorheben dazu
gehört die steigerung der attraktivität
der pflegeberufe
das geht durch höhere löhne und bessere
aber durch bessere arbeitsbedingungen
dankeschön auf verdi-mitglied durch das
geht durch höhere löhne das geht durch
bessere arbeitsbedingungen zum beispiel
oder vor allem auch durch bessere
personalbemessung instrumente durch
familienfreundliche arbeitszeiten und so
weiter und so fort wir brauchen wir
müssen die pflege im zusammenspiel im
gesundheitswesen aufwerten durch
heilkundliche tätigkeiten durch neue
berufsbilder wie die community herzen
haus in der gemeinde pflege und wir
brauchen mehr unterstützung für die
pflegenden familien auch durch
infrastruktur wie tages- und
kurzzeitpflege
das sind alles überfällige projekte in
den letzten jahrzehnten
vernachlässigt wurden und wir brauchen
mehr menschen die bereit sind in der
pflege zu arbeiten und zwar so schnell
wie möglich pflege muss für junge
menschen auch attraktiv sein und
deswegen fangen wir natürlich mit
ausbildung fort und weiterbildungen an
aber ich möchte auch über die
anerkennung ausländischer fachkräfte
reden die müssen wir endlich deutschland
weit harmonisieren ich meine bitte
eine herzliche bitte an die
bundesregierung und die bundesländer
jetzt möglichst schnell ein
bundeseinheitliches verfahren der
berufsanerkennung für pflegefachkräfte
aus der ukraine zu schaffen mit allem
was dazugehört mit sprachkursen und so
weiter und so fort und wenn dieses
verfahren etabliert es bitte auch auf
alle anderen ausländischen pflegekräften
die zu uns kommen anzuwenden wir
brauchen bundeseinheitlich lösen wir
müssen dieses hin und her zwischen den
bundesländern muss endlich ein ende
haben wir werden sonst den
demografischen wandel nicht meistern
können wir haben nicht mehr viel zeit
die steigende anzahl von menschen die
auf professionelle hilfe angewiesen sind
und die familien die sie unterstützen
ihnen zu helfen lassen sie uns gemeinsam
endlich ein massiv und gutes fundament
für die pflege schaffen ich danke
kordula schulz asche war das in der
debatte des bundestages über den etat
des
gesundheitsministers der diese natur
natürlich mit aufmerksamkeit verfolgt
der nächste redner jan schneider aus der
fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren es wäre wünschenswert
wenn staatliche haushalte die form von
unternehmensbilanzen hätten dann müsste
nämlich für die folgen verfehlter
politik rückstellungen gebildet werden
man würde im aktuellen haushalt schon
sehen was für kosten dazu künftig auf
uns zukommen und da wären nach zwei
jahren verfehlte corona politik einiges
im argen einige beispiele
infolge des lok downs haben die
fitnessstudios in deutschland 20 prozent
ihrer mitglieder verloren und die sind
auch nicht wieder zurückgekommen wenn
ich das mal übertrage auf andere
bereiche des breitensports dann bedeutet
das ein fünftel der menschen die vorher
vor krone regelmäßig sport getrieben
haben verbringen ihre freizeit
maßgeblich auf der couch in einer älter
werdenden gesellschaft ist das
tatsächlich ein problem das in
zukünftige kosten die dort auch unser
gesundheitssystem vorkommen eine dame
war
sie möchten es gerne dramatischer die
who schätzt dass eine million krebs
erkrankung unerkannt bieten auf
deutschland runtergeworfen sind das
200.000 fälle und jetzt sagen sie bitte
nicht das hing mit der überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zusammen unser
gesundheitssystem waren überlastet und
vorsorgeuntersuchungen finden statt bei
niedergelassenen ärzten und in deren
praxis herrschte zum teil der lehre weil
die leute sich nicht mehr zum arzt
trauten aufgrund der von ihm geführten
corona ängste meine damen und herren
verpasste vorsorge verspätet
eingeleitete therapien geringe
heilungschancen
längere therapien höhere kosten ihre
corona angst hat allein in diesem
bereich
erhebliche zusätzliche kosten verursacht
und sie wird viele menschen
lebensjahrzehnte kosten meine damen und
herren
aber das dramatische das ist tatsächlich
das was wir unseren kindern und
jugendlichen angetan haben wir alle
wissen doch unter freiem himmel an der
frischen luft findet eine infektion mit
corona nicht statt wir wissen auch für
kinder und jugendliche ohne
vorerkrankung ist corona weitestgehend
harmlos und gehen sie auf die straßen
dann sehen sie dort kinder die alleine
unterwegs sind und eine maske tragen und
dann frage ich mich was hat man diesen
kindern eigentlich erzählt und ich frage
mich was haben sich diejenigen die diese
kinder anscheinend vollkommen überzogene
vorstellungen von den gefahren von
corona vermittelt haben was haben
diejenigen sich eigentlich dabei gedacht
30 prozent aller jugendlichen
weisen zeichen psychischer störungen auf
die zahl der suizide unter jugendlichen
haben sich während corona vervierfacht
und herr minister lauterbach wenn sie im
oktober des vergangenen jahres verkündet
haben alle umgehen werden bis märz
entweder geimpft genießen oder
verstorben sein dann haben sie sich an
die spitze derjenigen gesetzt ein mehr
an die spitze derjenigen gesetz die in
diesem land mit vollkommen unbegründeten
schreckensszenarien und schreckens
prognosen paranoia und hysterie schüren
der minister laut gemacht dann tragen
sie für die folgen dieser paranoia und
diese angst die verantwortung
unsere regierung kann froh sein dass sie
ihren haushalt nicht in form einer
unternehmensbilanz veröffentlichen muss
dann könnte sie nämlich gleich das
insolvenzverfahren anmelden
jörg schneider für die fdp-fraktion
mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss in der
debatte über den gesundheitsetat
vielleicht ein paar zahlen zum thema
corona die aktuell sehen team
neuinfektionen gestern 318
1387 corona tote bislang
128.000 die longo wird folgen noch nicht
absehbar erich irlstorfer ist der
nächste redner aus der unionsfraktion er
ist mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss
ich kann nur sagen es freude einen
gesundheitspolitiker wenn man sieht
welchen beachtlichen finanziellen
einzelplan wir hier haben der ein
enormes potenzial entfalten könnte
lauterbach ich möchte ganz kurz auch
ihre rede zum anlass nehmen zu sagen ja
es ist klug vorsichtig zu sein da
brauchen wir überhaupt nicht drin aber
ich finde es genauso klug dass wenn man
ein virus kennt und wir bauen einen
passgenauen impfstoff haben dass man
dann reagiert deshalb finde ich dass
vorsorge gesetzte union für richtig
meine sehr geehrten kolleginnen und
kollegen
diese milliardenschwere finanzplan
bedeutet nicht automatisch
dass wir veränderungen erreichen und
diese veränderungen sind im
koalitionsvertrag
ja klar skizziert
nur eins ist auch klar am anfang steht
eine idee dann benötigt man geld und
dann muss man in die umsetzung kommen
das ist das was ihre aufgabe jetzt ist
und ich möchte hier schon auch nochmal
erwähnen es wurde ja das gkv system und
pflegeversicherung und dergleichen
angesprochen die beiden kolleginnen und
von den grünen kollegin schmeckt und
wörter haben das angemerkt ansprache von
einem heruntergewirtschafteten system
und dergleichen diese meinung teile ich
nicht
und ich kann nur eins sagen wenn es denn
so schlecht ist sie haben uns über jahre
erzählt bürgerversicherung werde die
lösung warum haben sie es dann nicht
umgesetzt sie sind jetzt in der
regierung hätten sie es doch gemacht
dieses systemwechsels sie haben nicht
den mut und vielleicht wissen sie auch
dass es falsch ist
ich möchte diese punkte hier anbringen
die mir besonders wichtig sind das ist
die pflege dieses jahr der dreiklang aus
pflegebedürftige angehörige und
mitarbeiterinnen
herr minister ich kann ihnen nur sagen
100 tage sind vergangen und das was sie
auf den weg gebracht haben hier für die
pflege ist ein murks bremswege bonus und
ist eine einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht was schadet den systemen
meinen augen weil es arbeit vernichtet
und weil es sowieso die ressourcen in
der pflege noch mal noch mal schlecht
und es wurde immer ja auch geredet von
pflegerin körnchen und so was wir auf
den weg gebracht haben ich kann nur
sagen bisher sehe ich nichts was in der
pflege wirklich eine richtung wäre wo
diese dinge die sie vorher angekündigt
haben umgesetzt werden das ist über
einen augen schwache ankündigung
erreichten
einigkeit finden sie eine geschriebene
sind hier können ich habe mich
eigentlich gefreut heißt die
kindergesundheit dass man hier
abgeordnete erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage
sie hatten gerade von dem pflegerin
förmlichen gesprochen und dass wir das
nicht wertschätzen würden aber wenn sie
mal genau hinschauen dann müssten sie
uns ja sagen können wie sie denn diese
pflegereform angefasst habe wie sie
refinanziert haben wir wissen dass wir
mitte des jahres dazukommen müssen den
pflege beitrag anzuheben weil wir in der
lage sind das all das was sie da in der
letzten wahlperiode beschlossen haben
gar nicht refinanziert waren und sie
keine tragfähige finanzierung geschaffen
haben wo sind ihre vorschläge dafür wird
das passieren sollte das thema
vorschlägen persönlich lösungen für die
kolleginnen so dass die regierungsarbeit
sein muss das was wir in unserer
verantwortung hatten haben wir durch
tarif maßnahmen hier geredet und wir
haben das natürlich auch mit dem
privaten pflegeunternehmen geregelt es
war kein einfacher weg aber wir wollten
als ordentliche bezahlung das haben wir
auf den weg gebrachten auch die
entlastung der angehörigen auch das
haben wir gemacht und das war auch
finanziert ich möchte aber hier
natürlich weiter fahren im bereich der
kinder- und jugendmedizin ich würde mir
wünschen weil wir alle wissen dass die
generalistische ausbildung für den
bereich der kinder- und jugendpflege
schwächen hat und das würde nicht mal
geld kosten sollen die evaluierung
gehört vorgezogen was wäre wichtig
neugeborenenscreening all diese dinge
damit wir auch schneller diagnosen
bekommen da bin ich bei einem punkt da
wo ich auch wieder froh dass das eine
gewisse auf bildung
endet in ihrem plan in ihrem
koalitionspläne und das war das thema
des chronischen fertig syndroms das
steht im koalitionsvertrag und damit
sehr für es ist eine ganz schwierige
erkrankung auch wenn es nur in
anführungszeichen 300.000 betroffene
gibt aber selbst eine erkrankungen und
rcf ist das hat keine lobby wir müssen
das in den mittelpunkt unserer politik
aufnehmen und ich bitte sie dazu dass
wir das hinbekommen wir werden als union
uns dafür einsetzen wir werden hier
konstruktiv mitarbeiten weil wir ins
gelingen verliebt sind und weil wir hier
nicht parteipolitische spielchen machen
long beach und rcf es ist eine medaille
mit zwei seiten ich danke den
selbsthilfegruppen ich danke frau
professor schreiben wogen durch frau
behrens dass sie hier nicht locker
lassen lassen sie uns das wirklich
angehen ich habe briefe aus dem raum
schwaben von bmg bekommen die waren
unterirdisch und nüchtern die möchte ich
nicht zitieren ich möchte das auch nicht
bewerten aber lassen wir unsere chancen
kamen ich bin mit der rede zumindest
dann in die frau präsidentin ich danke
ihnen und hoffe dass wir ein
konstruktives miteinander hinbekommen
erfuhr
ich erst opfer wahlkreis 214
freisinnigen unverkennbar war das und er
war der drittletzte redner in dieser
aussprache in der es nach wie vor um den
etat des gesundheitsministeriums
und damit auch des gesundheitsministers
geht und da waren schon einige
gesprächsangebote drin bei erich
irlstorfer heike engelhardt ist die
vorletzte rednerin aus der spd-fraktion
auch sie ist mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte kolleginnen liebe
freundinnen der demokratie als d
fraktion
wir haben in dieser woche bereits viel
zum haushalt allgemein und in dieser
debatte natürlich viel zum gesundheits
haushalt gehört
ich wollte eigentlich ganz bewusst nicht
auf die verschwurbelten ausführungen zur
impfung und zum infektionsschutz
eingehen jetzt muss ich aber dazu doch
kurz etwas sagen was ich hier wieder von
ganz rechts gehört habe zeigt mal wieder
deutlich dass es ihnen eben nicht um die
gesundheit der menschen in diesem land
geht
schrille töne in richtung des ministers
falsche zahlen zum personalentscheid für
das ministerium wer lesen kann ist im
vorteil niemand redet von pauschalen
kürzungen aber wir werden die pandemie
überwinden und dann weniger kräfte da
verbinden müssen und schon sind wir beim
haushalt das gesundheitsministerium hat
in diesem jahr einen etat von mehr als
52 milliarden euro
wie in den letzten jahren ist der
großteil dieser mittel für die folgen
und die bekämpfung der pandemie
vorgesehen nur mal zum vergleich vor
corona lag der etat über mehrere jahre
ziemlich konstant bei knapp über 15
milliarden euro begeben also alleine in
diesem einzelfall
37 milliarden euro mehr aus um die
pandemie zu bekämpfen dabei dürfen aber
die anderen aufgaben nicht zu kurz
kommen wir haben uns in dieser
legislatur viel vorgenommen wir wollen
unter anderem die pflege stärken wir
wollen eine eins-zu-eins-betreuung bei
den hebammen erreichen wir wollen die
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen mehr
als vorantreiben wir wollen psychische
krankheiten entstigmatisieren wir wollen
vielfalt ermöglicht und wir wollen noch
ganz viel mehr und das alles kostet wir
hoffen deshalb dass das
finanzministerium dafür auch die mittel
bereitstellen wird wenn wir demnächst
hier im parlament die gesetze dazu
verabschieden werden
auch
sind wir schutzsuchenden
schutzsuchenden aus der ganzen welt
gegenüber verpflichtet wir müssen und
wir wollen sicherstellen dass wir diese
menschen bestmöglich medizinisch
versorgen
die aktuellen schrecklichen
entwicklungen werden sicherlich zu
weiteren ungeplanten ausgaben führen und
lieber herr minister wenn sie dafür
zusätzliche mittel benötigen dann haben
sie die spd fraktion auf ihrer seite
was ich mir wünschen würde wäre dass
sich die angestrebte stärkere rolle in
der welt auch bei unseren zahlungen an
die multilateralen organisationen
ausdrückt
der einzel etwa 23 wurde war gestern
verhandelt aber gerade da wünsche ich
mir dass wir auch in der aktuellen lage
zum beispiel unsere beiträge für das
welternährungsprogramm oder für den
globalen fonds zur bekämpfung von aids
tuberkulose und malaria erhöhen
und bei allem verständnis und bei aller
einsicht in unsere ausgaben zum
verteidigungsetat
ich bin mir ganz sicher jeder cent den
wir in humanitäre hilfen investieren ist
ein beitrag zum weltfrieden
vielen dank
heike engel hat war dass aus der
spd-fraktion mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss und die debatte
wird geschlossen
werden von helge braun kennen sie noch
aus dem kanzleramt aber in dieser
legislaturperiode ist der bekanntermaßen
vorsitzender im haushaltsausschuss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister lauterbach
und ich freue mich auch dass klaus
holetschek als einziger
gesundheitsminister der länder heute
hier ist und der debatte folgt denn
gesundheit ist schließlich eine
gemeinsame aufgabe vielen dank für ihren
besuch
in dieser debatte haben mehrere redner
der koalition darauf hingewiesen was
eigentlich die bürgerinnen und bürger
von uns erwarten und das teile ich auch
nämlich dass er eine gute
gesundheitsversorgung bekommen die wenn
sie krank werden ihnen moderne medizin
auf bestem standard gewährleistet und es
gibt ebenso eine große erwartung in den
berufen die im gesundheitswesen tätig
sind das jetzt im dritten jahr der
pandemie die arbeitsbelastung wieder
sich der normalität nährt dass
arbeitsbedingungen sich verbessern und
genau dass es die erwartungen unserer
aufgabe und jetzt schaue ich in diesem
haushalt und frage mich was steht denn
darüber drin dass man die hoffnung haben
kann dass das auch wirklich passiert und
sie die rednerinnen und redner der
koalition an mehrere dinge angesprochen
was sie sich im koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen haben stärkung des
ländlichen raums stärkung pflegender
angehöriger und vieles andere mehr und
im haushalt findet sich dazu nicht und
es findet sich nicht nur nichts dazu im
haushalt sondern es ist auch so dass die
haushaltsspielräume in diesem haushalt
schon mehr als ausgereizt sind so dass
auch die erwartung dass da vielleicht
noch was kommt aus meiner sicht eher
gering ist sie eine mission für gott von
der polizei
bauen sie waren ja lange im kanzleramt
auch für den gesamtüberblick
zuständig und ist ihnen klar dass das
wesentliche dessen was wir im
gesundheitswesen und auch in der pflege
ausgeben ja beitrags finanziert ist und
der zuschuss ja nur einen kleinen anteil
ausmacht dessen was wir ausgeben im
gesundheitswesen und dieser zuschuss sei
auch noch mal allen hier gesagt der ist
ja dafür da
versicherungsfremde
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgaben
aufzunehmen und das ist die aufgabe des
zuschusses an den gesundheitsfonds und
wenn sie da vermisst haben
beispiele dafür wie wir unsere aufgaben
im koalitionsvertrag umsetzen wollen
dann ist das erstmal etwas was wir
innerhalb des leistungskataloges der spv
und der gkv leisten von ihnen erwarten
wir konzepte dafür und dass sie mit
gehen dafür dass wir die bereinigung
hinkriegen die aufgaben die
gesamtgesellschaftlich sind das sind zum
beispiel pandemie bedingte kosten dass
sie auch wirklich dann über den steuer
steuer haushalt finanziert werden ist
ihnen das klar weil sie haben gerade
eigentlich eine völlig falsche
herleitungen an der stelle vorgenommen
also ich habe ehrlich gesagt gedacht ist
ein bisschen länger bis der punkt kommt
ja ich habe ihn ein kleines bisschen
schon erwartet da will ich in deutlich
sagen mehrere ihrer redner haben eben
darauf hingewiesen dass man die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung eben
nicht mit versicherungsfremden
leistungen überlasten soll und deshalb
ist die frage ob das alles als die sich
da im koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen haben am ende in die gkv
gehört etwas über das man glaube ich als
erstes noch diskutieren ist das zweite
was sie glaube ich auch sehen müssen ist
das ja wir feststellen dass die gkv
schon jetzt erheblich unterfinanziert
ist und wenn man noch in die
mittelfristige finanzplanung schaut dann
mache ich mir richtig sorgen um die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung weil das
was karl lauterbach in den interviews in
sozialen im vorgriff auf dieses
gesundheit
finanzierungsgesetz ankündigt dass wir
nächstes jahr ein loch von 17 milliarden
haben dass er mindestens noch mal einen
zuschuss von fünf milliarden braucht um
die gkv überhaupt ohne dass zusätzliche
projekte die sie vielleicht vorhaben
umgesetzt werden können auch noch
finanziert werden dass das alles nicht
nur nicht in der mittelfristigen
finanzplanung
abgebildet ist sondern es ist sogar so
dass das was sie eben angesprochen haben
nämlich die finanzierungslasten der
korona handel mit offenkundig der
finanzminister davon ausgeht dass man
den bundeshaushalt des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit im
nächsten jahr mehr als halbieren kann
weil da so gut wie gar keine kosten mehr
anfallen und auch da sind die spielräume
ausgereizt also ich habe sehr sehr große
sorgen ob das was sie sich vorstellen
überhaupt realisierbar ist deshalb
herzlichen dank für diese frage
es ist aber eben nicht nur die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung die vor
großen finanzierungs herausforderungen
steht und da spielt natürlich die
aktuelle ukraine krise und die aktuelle
wirtschaftsentwicklung auch mit rein wir
rechnen mit einer stärkeren inflation
wir rechnen damit dass die wirtschaft
sich ganz so positiv entwickelt das
heißt diese 17 milliarden die wir im
nächsten jahr als lücke erwarten wird
möglicherweise noch größer und der
bundesfinanzminister hat von diesem pult
aus sehr deutlich gemacht dass er
zusätzliche belastungen für die
wirtschaft und für die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht will aber wenn es so kommt
dann ist eine beitragserhöhung im
bereich der gkv unausweichlich und sie
haben es ja eben gerade auch gesagt auch
im bereich der pflegeversicherung sind
beitragserhöhungen alles andere als
ausgeschlossen und die aufgabe muss er
da sein wenn wir wollen dass die
deutsche wirtschaft uns mit den
steuereinnahmen über diese krise trägt
dass wir es schaffen dass auch in
zukunft die beitrage in der summe aller
sozialversicherungen nicht über 40
prozent steigen das hat die bisherige
regierung immer geschafft und an dieser
grenze werden wir auch sie messen
neben gkv und pkv ist auch natürlich
sind die ausgaben für corona ganz
entscheidend und sie herr bundesminister
haben eingangs ihrer rede auch noch
einmal deutlich gemacht dass momentan
nicht nur die infektionszahlen ein
historisches hoch haben so viele
infektionen neuinfektionen gemeldet wie
am heutigen tag gab es in der ganzen
pandemie noch nicht und gerade vor dem
hintergrund des von ihnen angesprochenen
longo witt problems was eben nicht auch
schwere verläufe begrenzt ist sondern es
auch bei leichteren verläufen gibt muss
man sich schon sorgen machen zwei
drittel aller infektionen sind in der
amtszeit der neuen regierung entstanden
nur ein drittel in der ganzen zeit davor
sie lassen die zahlen die
infektionszahlen laufen und das bildet
sich auch im haushalt ab das bildet sich
auch im haushalt ab denn sie brauchen
gegenüber dem ersten regierungsentwurf
für die korona politik 18,8 milliarden
euro mehr und das ist eine aufgabe an
der müssen sie arbeiten erstes thema
testen beim thema testen muss natürlich
je mehr infektionen umso mehr getestet
werden aber wir haben und der kollege
klein hat ja auch sehr intensiv darüber
gesprochen was die aufgabe der länder
ist oder der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung wir haben und hat momentan
ein system dass der bund keine kontrolle
über das testen wirklich ausübt der
bundesrechnungshof hat das kritisiert
und die kassenärztliche vereinigung soll
die kontrolle durchführen verdient aber
umso mehr geld hier mehr insgesamt
ausgegeben wird dh dass andere als
system ist völlig falsch wenn man in das
dritte jahr der pandemie geht wenn man
weiß dass man dieses instrument noch
lange brauchen wird da muss man dafür
sorgen dass auch kosteneffizientes und
deshalb müssen sie dringend etwas ändern
an dem erstattung system für die tests
ganz entscheidend
dass da wir jetzt in einer woche leben
voi in weiten teilen die masten pflicht
weggefallen ist und wir in einer
situation wo nur sieben landkreise in
deutschland einen incidents von unter
1000 haben wir uns jetzt auf den weg
machen nur noch in hotspots die unklar
definiert sind über die länder die
fördermaßnahmen zu machen
sagt ja der bundesjustizminister jedes
mal dass er eigentlich der meinung ist
es gäbe keine überlastung phänomen und
keine belastungs phänomene mehr in den
krankenhäusern gleichzeitig haben sie
ihre bundesgesundheitsminister
entschieden dass sie ausgleichszahlungen
den krankenhäusern weiter fortgesetzt
werden geld das wir alle im
bundeshaushalt in die hand nehmen vom
steuerzahler dafür dass geplante
operationen ausfallen dass menschen und
deutschland ihre geplante
gallenoperation ihre geplante
leistenoperation jetzt nicht durchführen
können weil die belastungssituation im
gesundheitswesen durch den ausfall von
kolleginnen und kollegen immer noch so
hoch ist dass wir ohne die
ausgleichszahlungen nicht zurande kommen
und wenn das keine belastungssituation
und gesundheitswesen ist dann weiß ich
es auch nicht und deshalb meine
herzliche bitte arbeiten sie auch daran
dass wir aus diesem system heraus kommen
und dass wir eine dauerhaft
funktionierende system der
krankenhausfinanzierung bekommen das was
in den letzten jahren gibt dort auch
seitens der länder nicht investiert
worden ist ist keine qualität für unsere
gesundheitssystem die
krankenhausfinanzierung ist eine
zentrale aufgabe und auch darüber findet
sich nichts gutes in diesem
regierungsentwurf herzlichen dank
vielen dank weitere wortmeldungen zu
diesem einzelplan liegen mir nicht vor